HOLD.
TESTING TESTING TESTING
TESTING. GALLERY MY TEST.
SO
WE'LL GET STARTED IN EVERYONE
HERE. ME OKAY GOOD GOOD. THIS
IS THE STATE ASSEMBLY INSURANCE
COMMITTEE THE HEARING OF MAY
SEVENTH. TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY WE HAVE A. STANDARD
LANGUAGE THAT MUST BE READ INTO
THE RECORD. BECAUSE OF THE
UNUSUAL. FEATURES OF THIS
HEARING. TO START I'D LIKE TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF THAT HAVE
MADE A RETURN OF THE CAPITAL TO
HEAR BILLS. POSSIBLE. TO THAT
END I WILL NOW SHARE A FEW
NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF
OUR HEARING TODAY REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION TO HELP
PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY. AND TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. DUE TO THE CURRENT
STAY AT HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE. IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WERE
IN THE ROOM. HERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER. WE ARE HAVING
A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING IN THIS SPACE WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND KNOWS MEMBERS
PRESENTING A BILL. A MINIMAL
CONTINUE TO STAFF AND A LIMITED
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITOL BUILDING. AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE-PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THERE ARE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND WHEN I CALL FOR
TESTIMONY. AND I'LL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I ASK
THAT THE- PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE- THAT'S KIND OF A-
AN ALL ENCOMPASSING. ADVISORY
FOR ALL OF US. YOU CAN ACCEPT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE
DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN YOUR
SEE. IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES
IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
AND DO WE KNOW IF THERE ARE ANY
THEIR- OKAY WE HAVE SOME
WITNESSES IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM WHICH IS
LOCATED RIGHT HERE IN THE
CAPITOL BUILDING THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN. HERE TO MY LEFT. SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS. OF THESE WITNESSES.
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY FOR
THE STREAM FROM THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM SO
PLEASE BEAR WITH US WHILE WE-
ACCOMMODATE THAT. THERE'S ALSO
THE OPTION OF DIAL IN.
COMMENTARY COMMENTING WILL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICETHROUGH WHICH ANY
TESTIFYING CONTEST TO FIND A
BILL THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. FOR
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO.
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING. HIS OR HER
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED IF YOU REMAIN. IF
YOU WERE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST
A BILL YOU SHOULD REMAIN ON THE
LIVE LINE. AND WILL NEED TO
PLEASE MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
WERE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. JUST
A- COUPLE MORE ADVISORIES HERE.
IF YOU'RE HAVING A PROBLEM WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2086 IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF IN MY STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE. FULL OF CALIFORNIA. A
FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO ARE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS PLEASE NOTE THAT THE
MIKE'S HERE IN THE CHAMBER TURN
ON WHEN THE REYES SO PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER TO RESPOND
TO A ROLL CALL. OR ASK A
QUESTION OR PROVIDE A COMMON.
PLEASE ALSO RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE FOR SEEKING
RECOGNITION TO ASK A QUESTION
OR MAKE A COMMENT WHICH IS OUR
STANDARD OPERATING PROCEDURE
ANYWAY THERE ON THE FLOOR. SO
WITH THAT. LET ME WELCOME
MISTER RIVAS TO OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY AREAS. THANK YOU
MISTER RIVAS FOR JOINING US IN
A NOTE THE ITEM ELEVEN. AB
THREE THREE TWO NINE AUTHORED
BY. MYSELF HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM THE AGENDA. SO ITEM ELEVEN
IS. NADA. WE FIVE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS. AB TWENTY FORTY
NINE AB. TWENTY THREE NINETY
SEVEN. TWENTY THREE NINETY
EIGHT TWENTY THREE NINETY NINE
AND. TWO FOUR ZERO TWO. FOUR OF
THOSE ARE INSURANCE COMMITTEE
BILLS AND ONE IS A BILL BY MR
COOLEY- COULD I PLEASE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FIVE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS. MOST MOTION AND
SECOND. YES. ON THE COLLECTED
SOMETHING IMPORTANT WHICH IS TO
TAKE ROLAND CALL FOR THE QUORUM
YOU ALL KNEW THAT BUT YOU'RE
TOO POLITE TO ME SO LET'S-
LET'S TAKE ROLE AND MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A- QUORUM. DALY HERE.
DALY HERE MAYES MAYES PRESENT
BERMAN BERMAN PRESIDENT BIGELOW.
BIGELOW PRESENT RIVAS RIVAS
HERE CHAN CHAN HERE COOLEY
COOLEY HERE COOPER COOPER HERE
FRAZIER. FRAZIER HERE GIPSON
GIPSON HERE GRAYSON. GRAYSON
HERE COM LONGER KAMLAGER HERE
VOEPEL YO WOULD WOOD HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A QUORUM. AND WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ATTORNEY.
COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IS THERE ANY DESIRE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE STAFF WERE MANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. NOT NONE THE WERE
AWARE OF ALL RIGHT. GO AHEAD
AND VOTE THEN LET'S VOTE ON
THAT. DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES
MAYES AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE
BIGELOW BIGELOW- I CALLED RIVAS.
RIVAS BY CHAN CHAN HI COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER I
FRAZIER FRAZIER HI GIPSON
GIPSON HI GRAYSON GRAYSON HI
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I VOEPEL
VOEPEL ON I WOULD WOOD HI THIS.
UNANIMOUS VOTES GOOD GOOD THANK
YOU. ARE THE FIRST TO. NON
CONSENT ITEM WOULD BE MISSED
PROM LOGGERS BILL AB NINETEEN
NINETY THREE. THIS AS A SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS HAPPY
THURSDAY. I AM HERE TO ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE ON AB NINETEEN NINETY
THREE THE FAMILY CARE GIVER
ECONOMIC SECURITY ACT. THE
ACOUSTICS ARE SO GREAT IN THIS
ROOM I FEEL LIKE I WANT TO SING
STANDING HERE BUT I WILL NOT.
THAT'S NOT PART OF THE BATTLE.
I PROVIDERS WHO CARE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO AREN'T TO A
CHILD OR SPOUSE ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
CALIFORNIA LAW EXCLUDES PARENT
AND FOUND IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROVIDERS FROM
RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PAYMENT. ABOUT 22% OF
AYE IT JUST SAYS PROVIDERS.
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND MOSTLY FEMALE FALL
INTO THIS CATEGORY THESE
PROVIDERS WHO MAY BECOME
UNEMPLOYED DUE TO THE DEATH OF
THEIR LOVED ONES. ARE LEFT
WITHOUT A PAYCHECK OR ANY TYPE
OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT. AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE WOULD
EXTEND UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
ELIGIBILITY. TO A PARENT OR
SPOUSE I HSS PROVIDER WHOSE
PATIENCE AND LOVE ONE HAS DIED
OR ENDS UP AND EXTENDED CARE.
CARE GIVERS HELP CLIENTS WITH
MEALS PERSONAL CARE NEEDS AND
EVEN PARAMEDICAL SERVICES LIKE
MANAGING MEDICATION BLOOD
TESTING AND CATHERINE ARE YOU.
IN MANY CASES I HSS CARE GIVERS
BECOME THEIR CLIENTS ONLY
LIFELINE ESPECIALLY DURING A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC WHEN WE MUST
MAINTAIN PHYSICAL AND FACIAL
DISTANCING. THE COLBERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS SHINING A
LIGHT. ON THE PROBLEMS THAT
CALIFORNIA WORKERS FACE SUCH AS
LACKING PROTECTIVE GEAR CHILD
CARE OR EVEN ACCESS TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. WE MUST
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS A
PLACE FOR ALL WORKERS INCLUDING
SPOUSE AND PARENT I HSS
PROVIDERS ARE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT IN TIMES OF
GLOBAL CRISIS. AND IN NORMAL
TIMES TO. OR BECAUSE OF I'D
JUST AS CARE GIVERS MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
STATEWIDE RECEIVE THEIR CARE AT
HOME INSTEAD OF IN A NURSING
HOME. BY ELIMINATING THE NEED
FOR UNNECESSARY TRIPS TO
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES HOME CARE
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE
POPULATION FROM KOBE NINETEEN
AND PREVENTS THOSE FACILITIES
FROM BEING OVERCROWDED. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND
GET SOME FOR THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY STAGNANT WAGES AN
INSUFFICIENT BENEFITS HAVE
CREATED A DANGEROUS. SHORTAGE
OF CARE GIVERS. AS A RESULT
MANY CARE GIVERS ARE PARENTS
AND SPOUSES WHO HAVE SACRIFICED
THEIR CAREERS TO DO THE WORK
THEMSELVES. UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE IS A BASS LINE
PROTECTION THAT MOST WORKERS
RELY UPON EVEN IN NON CRISIS
TIME. WE NEED A PERMANENT
SOLUTION SO THAT FAMILY CARE
GIVERS HAVE BASIC EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTIONS ALL OF THE TIME. IN
THE SPIRIT OF MAINTAINING A
HEALTHY SOCIETY THAT TAKES CARE
OF ITS WORKERS I URGE MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF EXTENDING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TO A
PARENT AND SPOUSE I HSS
PROVIDERS. WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY IS CHRISTINE CHRISTINE
ABOUT HAMILTON WITH THE U. D.
W. ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY AND KATHLEEN WILLIAMS
WITH BABY SO SPECIAL. THANK YOU.
PERSON WHO'S IN THE GALLERY
WHO'S RIGHT HERE IN THE ROOM.
AND I THINK THERE'S A
MICROPHONE UP THERE AND YOU CAN
GO AHEAD AND. ARE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES ALL RIGHT GREAT.
HI MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MISTER CHAIR MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON I AM
WITH YOU W. THE UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS WE REPRESENT AYE HSS
PROVIDERS IN TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
UNDER THIS BILL IS A HUGE PART
ALREADY FOR US ON HAS BEEN FOR
SEVERAL YEARS- WE ARE THANKFUL
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM LONGER
FOR TAKING THIS ISSUE ON AND
FOR ALL THE MEMBERS THAT HAVE
SINCE SIGNED ON TO BE CO
AUTHORS- AND OF ESPECIALLY THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL IS JUST
EXTRAORDINARY. FOLKS HAVE
INDICATED THAT THIS THIS IS
GOING TO BE A TOUGH CLIMB
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC IN THE
STATE. THAT WE'RE ALL IN- THERE
IS SOME MINOR COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL. I WOULD ARGUE
THAT IT IS BECAUSE WE'RE IN A
PANDEMIC THAT WE NEED TO PASS
THIS BILL AND HAVE A- RECTIFY
THIS TERRIBLE EXCLUSION THAT
HAS EXISTED FOR DECADES. FOR
THESE WORKERS WHO LITERALLY
SACRIFICE THEIR CAREERS AND
THEIR JOBS OUTSIDE THE HOME TO
CARE FOR THEIR MOST VULNERABLE
LOVED ONES. I HEARD YOU IF YOU
DON'T KNOW ANY PARENTS OR
SPOUSES WHO ARE CARING FOR
THEIR LOVED ONES IN THE HOME.
TO TRY TO FIND OF PEOPLE TO
TALK TO THAT ARE IN THAT
POSITION. BECAUSE THEY REALLY
WILL OPEN YOUR HEART AND YOUR
MIND AND RECOGNIZE WHAT PEOPLE
ARE DEALING WITH AND THE-
SACRIFICES THAT THEY ARE MAKING.
OUR JOB IN CALIFORNIA IS TO
MAKE IT A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
AND IT CAN'T BE A CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL IF YOU'RE NOT ELIGIBLE
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE THE PARENT
OR THE SPOUSE. WE CAN SEE
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT IS LITERALLY THE
ONE THING THAT WILL KEEP
PEOPLE. IN THEIR HOMES AND FOOD
ON THE TABLE WHEN THEY LOSE
THEIR INCOME BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SOMETHING THEY HAD NO CONTROL
OVER. AND THAT IS THE SAME CASE
WITH THESE. HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE 85% OF WHOM ARE
WOMEN. THEY WILL HAVE NO
CONTROL AND NO OPTION IF THEIR
LOVED ONE THEIR CHILD OR THEIR
SPOUSE EITHER PASSES. OR IS
HOSPITALIZED. IN THEIR LEFT
WITHOUT A PAYCHECK. SO I'M
URGING YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL TODAY THIS IS A RIGHTEOUS
BILL. THE PANDEMIC IS SHOWING
IS EVEN MORE NECESSARY NOW THAN
IT WAS BEFORE. AND I WANT TO
POINT THAT AGAIN 85% OF THESE
ARE WOMEN AND SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HELPING WOMEN INVADE
POVERTY STAY IN THEIR HOMES IN
OFF THE STREETS. TO BECOME
HOMELESS SO THANK YOU. AGAIN
FOR THE MEMBERS WHO WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MS CALM
WATER THERE'S IS THERE AN
ADDITIONAL A- SUPPORTER I
BELIEVE THIS KATHLEEN WILLIAMS
WITH BABIES SO SPECIAL- SHOULD
BE JOINING US TELEPHONICALLY
ALL RIGHT THERE. GOOD ALL
PASSED THE MODERATOR. WHOSE.
OVERSEEING THE PHONE AND
COMMENTARY TO ENGAGE WITH US
NOW CAN YOU HEAR ME MISTER
MODERATOR. GOOD. DID I HEAR
THAT DID SHE COMMON. FOR MAKING
IT IS THE EIGHTEEN ANTI
MODERATE. AFTER. GO AHEAD THEN
IF YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO WANTS
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE-
PLEASE PROCEED. ONE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND HIGH- I
JUST WANTED TO SAY HI TO
EVERYBODY- ON THE BOARD- MY
NAME IS KATHLEEN WILLIAM I ASK
YOU TO PLEASE THE FOUR EIGHTY
NINETEEN NINETY THREE EXISTING
PARENTS AND SOUTH I'D JUST THE
RIGHT PROVIDERS FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS AFTER
THEIR LOVED ONE PASSES AWAY AT
SCHOOL IT LEAVES GRIEVING
FAMILIES FINANCED BY ACTUALLY
DEFINITELY. AND IN DANGER OF
LOSING EVERYTHING- AT THE WORST
TIME OF THEIR LIVES I KNOW THIS
FIRST HAND BECAUSE I HAD LIVED
THROUGH THIS WITH MY PRECIOUS I
CAN'T LIVE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX MY YOU
LIVE WITH DIAGNOSED WITH A
TERMINAL HEART DEFECT. IN UTERO
SIX WEEKS BEFORE HE WAS CUTE WE
WERE GIVEN THREE OPTION HEART
TRANSPLANT HEART TRANSPLANT
WHICH MOST BABIES DIE WAITING
BECAUSE IF IT HARD DO NOT
BECOME AVAILABLE. 63 DEGREES
WHICH WOULD AKE PLACE WITHIN A
FEW DAYS AFTER BIRTH AND I'M
CAPABLE OF THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO WATCH ARE SENT BY THE
SHUTDOWN IMPACT THE WAY WE
CHOSE A THREE STAGE SURGERY TO
AT LEAST GET KILLED THE
FIGHTING CHANCE FOR. LONG THAT
WOULD BE. I'M MY FULL TIME.
TEACHING CAREER TO BE CALEB
GIVER. DON'T CARE WITH KILLED
CARE WOULD BE A THE CLOCK TIME.
HIGHER HOURS WE FEEDING TO
DECLINE AND MANY LIVES MAY.
AFTER FIFTY THIRD. WHICH BEING
A OPEN HEART I'M MARTY TWO
THOUSAND. AT NIGHT AND A HALF
YEARS- KILLED LOSSES BATTLE AND
WENT HOME TO BE WITH THE LORD
JUST WHEN I THOUGHT THINGS
COULDN'T GET ANY WORK THEY DID
I FOUND OUT ABOUT THIS HORRIBLE
REGULATION OF THE- BAPTISM
COLLECTING UNEMPLOYMENT AFTER
THEIR CHILD IS ABOUT. THE WAIT
THIS IS A HORRIFIC CRIME THAT
TOOK ME ON A ROAD IN
DESPERATION TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT MY NEW NORM WELL FIGHTING
THREE SEARCHING FOR WHEN IT.
AND TRYING. AND TRYING TO PULL.
THROUGH THE HEART AT. EIGHTY
BEING WHATEVER HAVE TO IN. I
MANY LEVEL. HOWEVER EVEN THOUGH
YEARS HAVE PASSED I DON'T NOT
RECOVERED. AND STRAW MOTION WE
WITH PTSD. IN SPITE OF THESE
OBSTACLES I ABOUT THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO CHANGE THIS REGULATION
NOT ONLY TO KEEP. I REALIZED
BUT ALL THE SPECIAL ANGELS THAT
PASSED AWAY. THAT WOULD FOREVER
BE ETCHED IN OUR SCHOOLS. I
FINALLY REALIZED I WOULD NEVER
BE THE SAME I HAD BILLS PILING
UP AND NO MEANS TO PAY THEM. I
WITH THE DANGER OF LOSING
EVERYTHING. I CAN'T THIS IS A
BLESSING FOR FAMILIES LIKE MINE
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE CRIMES
YOUR CHILD. HOWEVER CARE GIVING
IS THE HARDEST JOB YOU'LL EVER
DO. BUT NO ONE WILL EVER DO IT
BETTER. WHEN THE PARENTS TALK
TO WRITERS LIKE I LOSE OUR
LOVED ONES. WE NEED THE SAME
PROTECTION AS ALL THE OTHER I
JUST AS WORKERS WE NEED IT NOW
MORE THAN. MORE THAN EVER GIVE
TO THE WORLD CURRENT PANDEMIC.
MY HEART HEAVY THINKING ABOUT
WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO THE PARENTS
SOUTH CARE GIVER TO LOSE THEIR
LOVED ONE. THERE I ADDRESSES.
DOCTORS GET THE NONEXISTENCE
NOW DUE TO CALL THE NINETEEN.
HOW IN THE MIDST. OF THE OVER
ONE GRIEF I YOU SUPPOSED TO
SPEAK EMPLOYMENT AN ECONOMY
THAT HAS NO JOBS AVAILABLE IN A
WORLD IN VIRTUALLY CLOSED DOWN.
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN TO THEM
AND HOW ARE THEY GOING TO
SURVIVE WITH NO REPORT IT. I AM
HERE TODAY BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
WHAT HAPPENED TO ME TO HAPPEN
TO ONE MORE CARE GIVER. PLEASE
DO THE RIGHT THING AND MAKE THE
CHANGES SO THAT THESE. SO MAKE
THE CHANGES WE ARE REQUESTING
TO THE BUDGET TO EXTEND
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TO THE
PARENTS ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH FOR LETTING ME HAVE THIS
MOMENT I APPRECIATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND YOUR
HEART FELT. WORDS THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH. ARE THERE OTHER
PERSONS WISHING TO ADD ON AS
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL. ANYONE
ELSE MISTER MISS MS EIGHTEEN
TEAM MODERATORS OR ANYONE ELSE
THAT YOU HAVE- IN THE SYSTEM
WHO IS DESIRING TO COMMENT. YES
SHARE A LINE. THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GO AHEAD. ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YEAH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A WONDERFUL-
MY NAME IS IRIS YOU'RE GONNA
TAKE I AM WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO. WORK THE
CELL. GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MS MODERATOR ANY OTHER OTHER
ADDITIONAL FOLKS IN THE QUEUE.
YES LINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
THIS IS MICHELLE GAIL CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN THE
SUPPORT THIS BILL AB ONE NINE
NINE THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE. THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE ON THE PHONE LINE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT. ARE THERE
PERSON WILL GO TO THE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
LIKE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS REALLY A
GRIPPING WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES- JUST NOT
IT NOT NEEDING TO- REITERATE
THE POINT THAT HAVE BEEN
ALREADY MADE BUT IN IN REALLY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT IN
THE QUEUE. THE BOTTOM LINE OF
WINE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IF ANY RIGHT NOW WITH SBI
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND LONG TERM CARE WORKERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. NEXT IN
THE QUEUE. MEXICO TO THE LINE
OF ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES. GREAT WHITE AMONG WE HAVE
THE DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO THE LINE OF LINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS MARIA SHAW AND I'M A-
WHICH TO BE AND- LA JUSTICE- I
SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT- AND IT.
IN ORDER TO GET UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AND PARENTS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS SHOULD PAY INTO
IT. THANK YOU. NEXT OPEN THE
LINE OF LINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THE THIRD AFTER
ONE ABOUT- I'M RIGHT I AGENTS
ARE COME CARE PROVIDER FOR MY
SON. AND A NUMBER OF UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS ROUGHLY LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY AND I URGE-
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT TO OPEN UP
MY APOLOGIES TO OPEN A LINE OF
LINE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES HELLO MY NAME IS
CONNIE CARP BLUE AND I'M A
MEMBER OF HAND IN HAND I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF. SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN I'M AND I ACCEPT THAT
WORKERS AND- NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE AND I'M A NON FAMILY
PROVIDER I'VE NEVER WORKED FOR
A FAMILY MEMBER BUT I.
DEFINITELY THAT- ESPECIALLY THE
SO SPEAKER WHO GAVE TESTIMONY
ARE SPELLED IT OUT VERY CLEARLY
WHY AIDS AND CARED IF THAT
PEOPLE. WHO ARE WORKING IN
THEIR OWN HOMES WITH THEIR OWN
FAMILY MEMBERS. NEED TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE WHEN THEY LOSE THEIR
JOBS. NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
TAKE. FOR DEBT. AND I URGE YOU
TO PASS THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I LEFT OPEN A LINE
OF LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I GET AFTERNOON HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LINDSAY EMI HONG AND
THE CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR FOR
HAND IN HAND THE DOMESTIC
EMPLOYERS NETWORK ON I JUST.
SPOKE ON OUR BEHALF IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE ORGANIZED. AS WERE
THE ONLY ORGANIZATION IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ORGANIZES THE
TWO MILLION HOUSEHOLDS THAT
HIGHER FOR HOUSE CLEANING HOME
CARE. AND CHILD CARE IN THEIR
HOMES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NO ADDITIONAL LINE
THANK YOU FOR PLEASE CONTINUE.
TO THE MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY.
FOLKS WHO HAVE PHONED IN ALL ON
THE OPPOSE. SIDE OF THE BILL.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
OPPOSE PATEL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE'S
NO ONE IN HOUSTON- THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY PERSONS IN THE
VIDEO. WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM WHETHER ANY
PERSONS IN THAT ROOM WHO ARE
WANTING TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CURRENTLY NOT. WELL THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ASK QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR I SEE MISTER GRAYSON'S
MICROPHONE IS A GO AHEAD SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS I
NEED TO ASK IN AND THEN ALSO A
FOLLOW UP WITH A COUPLE
COMMENTS- AND THESE QUESTIONS
MAY BE BETTER SERVED FOR THE
WITNESS- AS WELL AS THE AUTHOR.
BUT IS THE AYE HSS WORKER
CONSIDERED A TEN NINETY NINE
WORKER AND ALSO- WOULD THERE BE
PAYMENT MADE INTO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM
TO PROVIDE THIS BENEFIT. AND
THEN ON AVERAGE HOW MUCH IS AN
AYE HSS WORKER MAKING. SO I
WILL LET AND MISS HAMILTON
ANSWER SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS
BUT YES THE I. BECAUSE THOSE
WERE FOR WOULD BE PAYING IN TO-
THE FUN. AND THEN CRISTINA DO
YOU WANNA HELP WITH THE OTHER
BY- BUT THE AVERAGE YES THANK
YOU SO I JUST AS WORKERS ARE W.
TWO EMPLOYEES THEIR EMPLOYERS
RECORD WELL THE ACTUALLY HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT EMPLOYERS- BUT
THEY ARE EMPLOYEES THEY ARE NOT
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS THE
SECOND QUESTION- SORRY CLOSEST.
BY THE AVERAGE PAY FOR THE
AVERAGE PAY THE AVERAGE PAY
STATEWIDE IS THIRTEEN DOLLARS
AND TWENTY SOMETHING CENTS JUST
ABOVE THE MINIMUM WAGE. AND WE
I'M SORRY. YOUR FINE I JUST- SO
WE CAN GET TO THE OTHER TWO AND
LAST QUESTIONS AND THAT WAS
WHAT OF WHAT ACTUALLY WOULD
HAVE TO HAPPEN OF FOR. AND I
HSS WORKER TO BE DEEMED
ELIGIBLE FOR THE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. SO THAT'S A REALLY
GOOD QUESTION- THE WAY THAT
THIS LIKELY PLAYS OUT IS THAT
THEY LOSE EMPLOYMENT BY VIRTUE
OF THEIR CLIENT EITHER OR BEING
HOSPITALIZED FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OR THEY ARE PLACED INTO
AN INSTITUTION. OR THEY PASSED
AWAY- LIKE ANY OTHER WORKERS
WHO IS ELIGIBLE IN CALIFORNIA
THEY WOULD GO TO THE E. D. D.
WEBSITE AND FILE A CLAIM. SAME
FORMULA SAME WAITING PERIODS
SAME EVERYTHING THAT- ANY OTHER
WORKER WOULD HAVE TO ABIDE BY
THE SAME RULES- WE DID DO THE
CALCULATION SO THE AVERAGE
NUMBER. OUR CLIENT IS A HUNDRED
AND- ONE SO IF A WORKER WORK A
HUNDRED ON THAT THE MINIMUM
WAGE THEIR WEEKLY BENEFIT. THE
ESTIMATE WOULD BE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS A WEEK. IF THEY
WORK THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
HOURS THAT YOU'RE ALLOWED.
THROUGH AYE AYSHA ASSESS THEIR
MAX AT THEIR WEEKLY BENEFIT
WOULD BE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS A WEEK. THAT'S THE
MAXIMUM ALLOWED UNDER LAW AND
THE BENEFIT WOULD BE FOR TWENTY
SIX WEEKS. AND HOW HOW LONG
COULD THEY GET THAT BENEFIT
FOR. WHEN YOU SIX WEEKS THAT'S
THE MAXIMUM LENGTH. THAT WAS MY
LAST QUESTION IF I COULD JUST
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIR IN MOST OR MANY CASES- I
HSS WORKERS CARING FOR A
RELATIVE HAS HAD TO LEAVE
ANOTHER JOB. LEAVE A CAREER TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
RELATIVE- AND THAT OTHER JOB
MOST LIKELY PAID SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER WAGE AND INCLUDED THE
CERTAINTY OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE IS A PART OF THAT
JOB. AND IN SOME CASES IT UP IT
IS A SINGLE PARENT FOR US-
PERSON A SINGLE PERSON SINGLE
INCOME HOUSEHOLD THAT IS CARE
FOR A CHILD AND THAT THERE WAS
VERY LITTLE. SINS VIABLE
OPTIONS OTHER THAN THEM LEAVING
THAT CAREER AND COMING UP OR
STE HOME AND TAKE CARE OF THEIR
CHILD OR THEIR- I'M- I'M MORE
TO CRY. I A GET THE FACT THAT
WE'RE GOING FROM ONE CRISIS TO
ANOTHER- AS FAR AS ECONOMIC- I
KNOW THERE'S SOME ECONOMIC COST
OF THIS. I WILL LEAVE THAT UP
TO A DIFFERENT COMMITTEE- AS
FAR AS I'M CONCERNED I AM GOING
TO VOTE FOR THIS AND SUPPORT
THIS TODAY ON THE MERITS OF THE
BILL. AND I BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULDBE PROVIDING. AND DID SO
AS EMPLOYMENT AND A JOB THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER
GRAYSON- MR VOEPEL HAS HIS MIKE
OF PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR WITH
YOUR QUESTION OR COMMENT. YES
MISTER TERRY COLLEAGUES I HAVE
A I SUPPORT THIS BILL TO GOOD
BILL BUT I HAVE A TECHNICAL
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR. AND
REQUEST PERMISSION TO READ THE
SHORT PARAGRAPH THAT I HAVE A
QUESTION ON. YEAH PLEASE GO
AHEAD VERY WELL. THIS SECTION
OF THE BILL IS THIS BILL WOULD
INCLUDE A CHANGE IN STATE
STATUTE THAT WOULD RESULT IN A
TAXPAYER PAYING A HIGHER TAX
WITHIN THE MEANING OF SECTION
THREE OF ARTICLE THIRTEEN A OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION AND
THOSE WOULD REQUIRE FOR PASSAGE
THE APPROVAL OF TWO. OF THE
MEMBERS BEACH HOUSE IN THE
LEGISLATURE MY QUESTION IS.
WHO'S THE TAXPAYER IS THAT THE
EMPLOYER IS IT SPLIT BETWEEN
THE EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE IS IT A-
INCREASE IN OUR STATE INCOME
TAX IS IT A BOND THAT WILL BE
FLOATED I DON'T KNOW WHO THE
TAX PAYER IS. THAT IS A GOOD
TECHNICAL QUESTION I DON'T HAVE
THE ANSWER TO THAT RIGHT NOW-
AND I I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE WE GO
THANK YOU I CAN'T SEE THE SONGS.
I'M TRYING TO SEE OKAY THERE WE
GO- THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION SO. THE WAY
UNEMPLOYMENT WORKS- THIS ISN'T.
IT NATIONALLY THE EMPLOYEE
YOU'RE- PAYS A CONTRIBUTION
INTO THE U. I FIND ON BEHALF OF
THE EMPLOYEE IT'S MANDATORY FOR
THE EMPLOYER. FOR THE 80% OF I
JUST AS WORKERS THAT ARE
COVERED ALREADY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PAYS THEIR
CONTRIBUTION INTO THE U. I.
FUND FOR THEM. THE CONTRIBUTION
IS TECHNICALLY A TAX THAT'S WHY
THE LEDGE COUNCIL CUTE AS A TWO
THIRDS BUT THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
NO TAX ON ANYBODY OR ANY
BUSINESS OR ANYTHING RESULTING
FROM THE BILL IT IS THE STATE
MAKING THE CONTRIBUTION ON
BEHALF OF THIS SUBSET OF NEW
WORKERS. AND THE CONTRIBUTION
JUST TO GIVE YOU A PERSPECTIVE.
LAST YEAR THE LAST FISCAL YEAR
THE HOW THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CONTRIBUTED TWENTY ONE MILLION%
ON BEHALF OF THE 80% OF THE
WORKERS SO THAT'S HOW WE
EXTRAPOLATED THAT THE COST FOR
THIS. ALERT SUBSET OF 20% WOULD
BE APPROXIMATELY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS SO THERE'S NO THEY
WOULDN'T THEY WOULDN'T BE
DRAWING FUND THE FUN WITHOUT
HAVING PUT CONTRIBUTIONS IN. IT
I THERE'S BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT
THE SOLVENCY OF THE FUND IS A
VERY LEGITIMATE THIS WOULD MAKE
CONTRIBUTION WE OF THE NEW
GROUP. WHO THEN MAY. HAVE TO
YOU KNOW CALL ON A IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU. SO QUICK
FOLLOW UP THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT
I SAW IT IN THIS BILL
TECHNICALLY THEN IT'S A STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TAX IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WOULD THAT BE A
CORRECT STATEMENT. YES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL-
FOR YOUR QUESTION ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTER MAYES JUST A QUICK
COMMENT ON THE POLICY OF
SUPPORT THIS I'D LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF THAT'S
OKAY. THANK YOU. BEEN POINTED
OUT THIS SIR. THIS BILL WILL
LARA. BE ONE OF THE MANY-
SUBJECTS IN THE BUDGET. PROCESS
WHICH THIS YEAR WILL BE.
REMARKABLY MORE DIFFICULT THAN
IN PAST YEARS. OUR JOB IS TO
LOOK AT THE POLICY. AND EIGHT
THE VICE CHAIR HAS A SIGN ON AS
A CO AUTHOR ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. MISS
CALM WATER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
WRAP IT UP PLEASE YEAH I WANNA
THING- MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR-
VERY ACUTE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS ABOUT THE FUN. I WON I
THINK THE VICE CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- LOAD I CARE
FOR AND ASKING TO BE A CO
AUTHOR- IN THAT THEY WOULD FOR
SIGNALING. SUPPORT OF SOME KIND
HE CO AUTHOR HERS WILL BE-
ADDED ONCE THIS GETS OUT OF
COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY
THIS BILL EXPOSES. FRAGILITY
THEN OUR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SYSTEM- I'M AND WHAT WE DO KNOW
IS THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE
PLACING AN ARBITRARY VALUE. ON
A ON A CLIENT- AND DENYING
EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
ACCESS. BECAUSE A PATIENT OR
CLIENT HAPPENS TO BE A SPOUSE.
OR A CHILD. THE I RESPECTFUL
ASK FOR YOUR THOSE ON EIGHTY
NINE. NINETY THREE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER AS I
SAID THE CHAIR IS RECOMMENDING
A SUPPORT POSITION. AND IF
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
WILL GO AHEAD AND DO A ROLL
CALL VOTE. ACTUALLY I NEED A
MOTION ON THE WAS A MOTION AND
A SECOND THAT'S RIGHT. THAT'S
RIGHT IT'S BEEN MOTION AND
SECONDED ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
DALY HI DALY AYE MAYES. MAYES
AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW HI RIVAS. RIVAS HI
CHAN. CHAN HI COOLEY. COOLEY
AYE COOPER. COOPER AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON. GIPSON R.
I. GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE COM
LONGER KAMLAGER I WILL TELL.
HELLO HI WOULD WOOD HI THAT'S
FOURTEEN ZERO. FOURTEEN ZERO
WELL DONE MYSTERON LONGER WELL
DONE THANK YOU FOR ALL THE ALL
THE TESTIMONY FROM VARIOUS
INTERESTED PARTIES. SO THE NEXT
BILL PRESENTATION IS MY OWN
BILL I'VE GIVEN THE GAVEL TO MR
MAYS SO WATCH OUT. Q. ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SIX MR DALY CITY FORGERS.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
MEASURE PROPOSES A MARKET BASED
SOLUTION. TO THE CURRENTLY
DISRUPTED MARKET FOR HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE IN OUR STATE HI FIRE
RISK REGION'S. EXISTING LAW
LIMITS THE FLEXIBILITY FOR
INSURERS TO FIND ECONOMICALLY
REASONABLE WAYS TO ISSUE
POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
FIRE WRIST REGIONS AND
COUNTIES. THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
EACH INSURER WHO CHOOSES TO
PARTICIPATE. TO FILE A SPECIFIC
PLAN THAT ADDRESSES THAT
INSURANCE NEEDS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. IF THE
PLAN IS APPROVED BY THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER. AND
ONLY OF. THE PARTICIPATING IN
SURE WILL BE SUBJECT TO A LEGAL
MANDATE TO INCREASE THE VOLUME
OF POLICIES IT OFFERS TO
HOMEOWNERS IN CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
RISK REGION'S. INCLUDING
COUNTIES ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
ADDRESSES WHICH COUNTIES THE
PROGRAM APPLIES TO AND HAD A
MEASURE AND INSURANCE
COMPLIANCE. WITH ITS MANDATE TO
ISSUE MORE POLICIES. I I'M
AWARE THAT THERE ARE PARTY
SHOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL. AND IF THIS WOULD
BE THE TIME. MR MILLER BY THE
MICHELLE IT'S GOOD TO A
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AND- I
THINK WE'VE GOT SOME. THEY'VE
FOLKS UP OR THAT THEY'RE THEY
ON GONNA BE ON THE SCREEN
THEY'RE HERE ONE TWENTY FIVE.
SAYS GOOD OF THE TESTIMONY
OVER. TO THE VIDEO I GUESS
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE VIDEO. DO
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND-
BUT LET'S GO TO THE TESTIMONY
SUPPORT I THINK WE'RE GONNA BE
ON VIDEO HERE. THE MOVE THE
FIRST WITNESS. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS SERVE TAYLOR
WITH THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION. PRECIADO
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
AND THE DIGITAL PRECAUTIONS
EVERYONE IS TAKING HELP MAKE
OUR DEMOCRACY WORK SAFELY- I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
AUTHORIZED TO SAY THAT THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALLY.
CHURCH SO SEE ASIAN PACIFIC
ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES A LOT OF
ACRONYMS THERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES SHERRI VIRTUES HERE
TODAY AS WELL JOIN ME IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN YEAH SB TWO NINETY TWO.
WHICH MUST BE ENACTED JOINTLY
TO BECOME OPERATE. YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR WE WERE GIVEN PRETTY
CLEAR DIRECTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
GET COMFORTABLE BEING
UNCOMFORTABLE. AND TO WORK ON
SOLUTIONS TO THE CHALLENGES
SOME HOMEOWNERS IN HIGH FIRE
THREAT AREAS ARE EXPERIENCING.
WITH REGARD TO FINDING  POLICY
FROM IT'D BE IT'D MARKETED SURE.
WITH THAT IN MIND WE BELIEVE
THAT THESE MEASURES PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. IT
REQUIRES INSURERS WITHIN
APPROVED BY MAPS AND CHARTS
MARKET ACTION PLAN TO WRITE HI
FIRE RISK AREAS IT WILL ALSO
HELP REDUCE RISK AND LOSS.
INDIVIDUAL HOME HARDENING A
COMMUNITY WIDE MITIGATION. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
CURRENT INSURANCE AVAILABILITY
ISSUES ARE DIRECTLY RELATED TO
UNSUSTAINABLY LOW STATEWIDE
AVERAGE PRICE LEVELS. ACCORDING
TO THE MOST RECENT NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER DATA. CALIFORNIA'S
AVERAGE HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE
PREMIUM ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
DOLLARS IS 17% BELOW THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AND ALMOST ONE
HALF OF THE AVERAGE PRICE OF
HER CAN STATES LIKE LOUISIANA
FLORIDA. EVEN THOUGH IT'S
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS EXPENSIVE TO
REBUILD A HOME IN THOSE LOWER
COST GULF STATES. SO IN FACT
WHILE THE AVERAGE PRICE OF
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE IN THE
UNITED STATES HAS INCREASED
253% IN THE PAST TEN YEARS. AND
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY RESERVE TEN
POINT 6% JUST LESS THAN HALF
THE RATE OF INFLATION. SO ANY
FEASIBLE SOLUTION TO THE
AVAILABILITY ISSUE IN HIGH RISK
AREAS. MUST RECOGNIZE THE
ECONOMIC REALITY OF LOW AVERAGE
RATES AND THE TWENTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS OF LOSSES
INCURRED BY HOME INSURERS. AS A
RESULT OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES.
WHICH AS NOTED BY MOODY'S
INVESTORS SERVICE DR
CALIFORNIA'S HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE LOSS RATIOS TO THE
HIGHEST IN THE NATION. THE
STATUS QUO IS UNSUSTAINABLE IN
THIS NEW NORMAL. WE THINK THESE
BILLS PROVIDE INNOVATIVE
APPROACH THAT BALANCES INSURERS
RISK IN RATES IN COMBINATION
WITH A SUBSTANTIVE EFFORT TO
MITIGATE WILDFIRE RISK AND LOSS
IN THE LONGER TERM. AND IT IS
AN APPROACH THAT INSURERS CAN
SUPPORT WITHOUT FEAR OF
INSOLVENCY. FURTHER WE DISTRICT
REDUCING RISK OF LOSS IS THE
ONLY WAY TO REDUCE THE UPWARD
PRESSURE ON INSURANCE RATES. IN
SHORT IF THIS BILL IS ENACTED
AND THE COMMISSION APPROVED AND
I MAC WE WILL BE BOUND BY THE
MANDATE TO PROVIDE INSURANCE
THAT COMES WITH IT. WITH THAT
UP CLOSE I BELIEVE MY COLLEAGUE
SURE Q. I HAVE A FEW WORDS TO
SAY AND THEY WILL TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
TAYLOR MOVE UP TO THE NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US TODAY
THIS IS SOME. VERY DIFFERENT
FOR ALL OF US AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
ACCOMMODATE- JERRY MCKEE
REPRESENT IN THE PACIFIC
ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO ADDRESS
THE NEED TO IMPROVE THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE ADMITTED
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE MARKET-
COVERAGE. AND HIGH RISK AREAS.
OF IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE DEAL
WITH THE ISSUE OF RATES AND
RISK THAT HAS EVOLVED OVER
TIME. THE SOONER WE CAN FIND AT
A RATE OF WAYS- TO DO SO WE
WILL BE BETTER OFF IN THE HIGH
RISK AREAS. WE THINK THIS IS A
WORKABLE SOLUTION THAT MANY.
WILL BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM
AND HOPEFULLY ALSO IMPROVE
AVAILABILITY AND THE HIGH RISK
AREAS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
COMISKEY BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY
OTHER BELL. TESTIMONY BUT WE
WILL MOVE TO MAKE ME TO USE- SO
BY THE TELEPHONE MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYBODY THERE TO. DO YOU
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE. THIS
IS FOR THE REMINDER IF YOU'D
LIKE. AS A REMINDER IF YOU HAVE
A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IS FOR THOSE
WHO SUPPORT IS THAT ON THE ME
TO USE. HERE FOR THOSE WHO
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE TO AT THE
TIME SIR. RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. HIS WILL MOVE TO- IS
THERE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. RE GOING BACK TO
THE TO THE SCREEN FOR THAT. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTOOD THAT WE DID HAVE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR THEY-
YES. TWO MORE GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY INSURANCE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR GIVING
US THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO TESTIFIED HERE BEFORE YOU
ENTERED THE IS VERY
UNPRECEDENTED EXTRAORDINARY
TIMES MIKE MARTINEZ SENIOR
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA OF
INSURANCE HERE ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWO ONE SIX SEVEN. I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE HERE BRENT HANLEY.
SHARON AND SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
THE COMMISSIONER HERE WITH ME
TO HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS. SO
PLEASE KNOW THAT COMMISSIONER
WATER IN THE DEPARTMENT WE DID
NOT COME TO THIS DECISION
LIGHTLY TO OPPOSE AB TWO ONE
SIX SEVEN. HOWEVER THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE WITH THIS MEASURE
GREATLY OUTNUMBER ANY BENEFITS
TO IT. THE QUESTION AT THE CRUX
OF THE DEPARTMENTS OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE IS. WHAT IS
WRONG WITH THE CURRENT RATE
MAKING PROCESS UNDER
PROPOSITION ONE OF THREE AND
WHY DO WE NEED AN ADDITIONAL
SEPARATE FAST TRACKED PROCESS
TO ADDRESS THE BILL ABILITY TO
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE ACROSS OUR
STATE. TO DATE THERE HAS NOT
BEEN ANY CLEAR AND CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE PRESENTED TO
COMMISSIONER A LOT OF AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE THAT
THERE IS A MAJOR PROBLEM WITH
THE CURRENT RATE MAKING
PROCESS. TO THE CONTRARY THE
DEPARTMENT BELIEVES THAT THE
CURRENT RATE MAKING PROCESS
PRESCRIBED UNDER PROPOSITION
ONE OF THREE. IS AVAILABLE FOR
INSURERS TO REQUEST ADEQUATE
RATE TODAY. INDEED INSURANCE
COMMIT INSURANCE COMPANIES HAVE
SUBMITTED RATE APPLICATIONS IN
UNPRECEDENTED. NUMBERS THESE
PAST FEW YEARS. AND WHEN I AM
SURE CAN CLEARLY DEMONSTRATE
THAT A FILE GREAT IS NOT
EXCESSIVE. INADEQUATE FOR IN
FAIRLY DISCRIMINATORY THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ACTUALLY HAS
APPROVED THAT INCREASE IN FACT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS APPROVED TWO
HUNDRED AND TEN. HOMEOWNERS
RATE INCREASES FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN THROUGH TWENTY NINETEEN.
THAT MEANS MANY INSURERS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN RECEIVING MULTIPLE
RATE INCREASES WHICH WE BELIEVE
IS A DIRECT CONTRAST SUGGESTION
MADE BY SOME IN THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS NOT ADEQUATELY APPROVING
BREAK REQUEST MADE BY INSURERS.
AND AN ASSERTION AND COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS THAT RATES ARE
ADEQUATE ACROSS THE BOARD.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS ALREADY
MAINTENANCE DOUBLE DIGIT. AND
EVEN TRIPLE DIGIT INCREASES FOR
MANY POLICY HOLDERS ACROSS THE
STATE ESPECIALLY IN HIGH RISK
LOCATIONS AND WHAT WE- AND YET
THAT IS STILL NOT ENOUGH
BECAUSE THIS BILL WOULD. CREATE
A FAST TRACK AROUND THE CURRENT
ESTABLISHED PROPOSITION ONE OF
THREE RATE APPROVAL PROCESS AT
THE DEPARTMENT WITHOUT CLEAR
EVIDENCE. AT THE EXISTING
PROCESS DOES NOT WORK. ALLOW N
INSURER TO COMPEL EXPEDITED
APPROVAL FROM THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER FOR RATE
FLEXIBILITY WHICH WILL LEAD TO
EXCESSIVE RATES FOR CONSUMERS
WITHOUT ANY GUARANTEE OF
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS ROAD
LOST THEIR COVERAGE. IT'S
CIRCUMVENT THE AUTHORITY OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AN
EXISTING DEPARTMENT REGULATIONS
WHEN DETERMINING WHETHER UNDER
REGULATED THE INSURANCE SHOULD
BE ENTIRELY INCLUDED AS A
FACTOR IN SETTING RATES. AND WE
CAN CONSUMER PARTICIPATION AND
THE RATE MAKING PROCESS BY
RESTRICTING INTERVENOR
PARTICIPATION IN THE INSURANCE
MARKET ACTUAL PLAN PROCESS. IN
CLOSING- JUST THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA. WE BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY AND SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED CONSUMER. IT'S OVER
TIME WHILE THE SAME TIME WE CAN.
CONSUMER PARTICIPATION RATE
MAKING PROCESS IN LIGHT OF THE
UNKNOWN RAMIFICATIONS OF OUR
PANDEMIC WE ARE IN FOR THE LONG
TIME I HAD NOW IS NOT THE TIME
TO WEEKEND LONGSTANDING
CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWS THAT
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND HARD WORKING
FAMILIES FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE POSTED THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH I THINK
IS DO WE HAVE ANY MORE A MORE-
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION. WE DO
A- I WILL GATHER GOING TO GO TO
THE TO THE ME TO USE- I KNOW WE
HAVE SOMEBODY ON. OKAY TE
MODERATOR WE DO SOMEONE GOT A
MODERATOR I'VE GOT SOME FOLKS
ARE CALLING IN OPPOSITION. FOR
THOSE WHO ARE NOT POSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THE OVER
THE PHONE LINE. FIRST OF ALL TO
THE LINE OF LINE NUMBER SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN UP. OKAY LINE
FIFTY REMOVE THEMSELVES WELCOME
TO A LINE OF ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. PLEASE
GET PLEASE WHAT. YES MISTER BY
TERMINATE CHAIRMAN DALY AND
MEMBERS ROBERT AROUND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA I'M
GLAD YOU'RE ALL TRYING TO STAY
SAFE AT THE MINE. THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY STRONGLY OPPOSED.
TO EIGHTY TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. A BOOK FOR AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN THE FAMILY OF BEAU
TECHIES TO BE INCREASED
INSURANCE PREMIUM BUT
CALIFORNIANS TO THE TUNE OF
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WITH JUST A FRACTION OF THE
SCRUTINY THEY RIGHTLY MERIT.
THIS REPRESENTS THE COMPLETE
AND RUN AROUND CURRENT PRIOR
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR HOMEOWNER
INSURANCE RATES. THERE IS A
BETTER WAY- THIS COMMITTEE
UNFORTUNATELY HAS REFUSED TO
HEAR A BILL TRULY WORTHY OF
DISCUSSION AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY SEVEN. FIVE SEVEN MEMBERS
GONZALEZ AND MARK. INSTEAD WE
THE REST OF THE PUBLIC A FOURTH
RESPOND TO THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY'S WHICH WITH AS
CONTAINED IN THIS BILL. IN THE
CASE OF THE WORK GLOBAL
PANDEMIC IN THE CENTURY. AND
WITH MORE THAN FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. HE FOR THE COST
OUT OF WORK THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY'S RESPONSE TO RENDER
LARGELY USELESS. TECH IS THE
PROTECTION THAT IS SAFE
CALIFORNIA POLICY HOLDERS
BILLIONS. WE DON'T LET THE FAR
GUARDING HOUSE. BUT NO ON AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR- NEVER GO
BACK TO THE MODERATOR IS OR
SOMEONE ELSE ON THE LINE AND
IT'S GOING TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THINK USER AT THIS TIME.
OKAY SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY MORE
THE ANY JUST ADD ONS FOR
OPPOSITION EITHER CORRECT. OKAY
GREAT WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR- ANY QUESTION
SEVEN I RECOGNIZE MISTER COOLEY.
WELL AS I CHOOSE TO STAND I
BROUGHT SOME EXHIBITS WITH ME
BUT I WANT TO SPEAK. VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THE
USUAL WILDFIRE CALIFORNIA IS
SOMETHING IS DIFFERENT KIND AND
WE HAVE EXPERIENCE BEFORE. YOU
KNOW I THINK BACK TO NINETEEN
NINETY ONE WHEN THEY HAD THE
OAKLAND HILLS FIRE. WE LOST
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS
IN THE OAKLAND HILLS FIRE IN
THE FALL OF NINETEEN NINETY
ONE. THAT SHOCKED EVERYBODY.
FOR THE NUMBER OF LAWSUITS AND
YET THAT WAS IN THE DAYS WHEN
FIRE SEASONS CAME AND WENT
WE'VE HAD FIRES NOW WERE
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND AND MORE
STRUCTURES HAVE BEEN LOST
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
LOST YOUR AROUND FIRES. I HAVE
WITH ME A BUCKLE FROM A TRUNK%
IT WAS ALL THAT WAS LEFT IN THE
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR FIRE IN
THE HILLS ABOVE MALIBU. YOU
KNOW THAT WAS A DIFFERENT ERA
WHEN WE HAD THOSE SORTS OF
FIRES. I HAVE WITH ME A PIECE
OF A TREE TRUNK. THIS BILL
DEALS OF WILD URBAN INTERFACE
THIS IS FOR THE WHITE HALL FIRE
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR UP HIGHWAY
FIFTY CAN BE. A DIFFERENT ERA.
THIS BILL IS AN EFFORT THAT
FITS TO ME WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE'S ALWAYS
DONE. FOR MORE THAN A HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS CALIFORNIA LONG
INSURANCE AREA HAS BEEN. THAT
THE COMMISSIONER SHALL PERFORM
THE DUTIES IMPOSED UPON HIM OR
HER BY THE PROVISION THE CODE.
AND OTHER LARGE RING THE BIZ OF
INSURANCE. THE LEGISLATURE DOES
SET THE TABLE. ON SO MANY
INSURANCE QUESTIONS. WHEN WE
REALIZED AFTER NORTHRIDGE. BUT
THE PERIL OF EARTHQUAKE WAS
GETTING DIFFERENT IN KIND. WE
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY. THAT
INCORPORATED A PROVISIONAL LAW
TWELVE EIGHT EIGHTY POINT SIX.
WHO WHO THE DON'T WITH
ESTABLISHING A TECHNICAL BASIS
FOR EVALUATING EARTHQUAKE RATES.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES THE
I. AP TOOL THE MARK CONSISTS
OF TOOL IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR THE LONGEST
TIME IT'S AN ALTERNATIVE
MECHANISM THAT MARKETS CAN USE
TO DO WITH MARKET DISRUPTION.
YOU'VE HEARD OF JOINT OF.
ASSIGNED RISK PLANS JAY YOU A-
OF STATE REINSURANCE STATE PARK
SPONSORS FOR A FRIEND MARKET
PLAYERS ARE JUST ONE OF MANY
TOOLS IN COMMON USE IN THE
INSURANCE MARKET PLACE
NATIONALLY WHAT DOES IT DO WHAT
IS THE ADVANTAGE IT CAN FOR.
MOST OF YOUR HOMEOWNERS
INSURERS ARE REALLY MORE FOCUS
ON URBAN AREA. WE ARE
ENCOUNTERING PROBLEMS ON AND
FIRE HAZARD JONES WILDLAND
URBAN AREAS. IT WILL ESTABLISH
AN INFORMED BASIS FOR ANALYZING
THE RISK IN THOSE AREAS IT'S
THAT'S THE MARKET ASSISTANCE
PLAN IT IS A STUDY. TO
UNDERSTAND IT AND MAKE PUBLIC A
RESOURCE TO CONSTRUCT TO PARSE
THE RESEARCH THERE. THAT THE
INSURER IS THEN ASKED TO INSURE.
THAT TOOL BECAUSE AS THE PUBLIC
TOOL WILL ALLOW THE PEOPLE IN.
OF MOUNT SHASTA OR HEALDSBURG
OR OF FOR TUNA UP THE COAST. TO
LOOK AT THIS TOOL AND HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND WHAT MIGHT BE THEIR
WRISTS AS A CITY OR IS A COUNTY
IT WILL SHED LIGHT ON THOSE
RESTORED AS A PUBLIC TOOL WILL
CONFER BENEFITTED PLANNING AND
BECAUSE IT IS WILL SYSTEMATIZED
EXAMINATION AND DEPTH OF THESE
RISKS IT BECOMES A TOOL OF THE
PRIVATE MARKET PLACE THAT IS
THINKING ABOUT ENSURING. CAN
LOOK AT THEIR EXPOSURE LOOKING
THROUGH THE LENS OF THIS STUDY.
AND THEN- DECIDE THAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO COME IN IT KICKS IN
WHEN THERE IS A MARKET
DISLOCATION. OF SO IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT WAY IT IS A
NEW TOOL IN THE TOOL KIT TO A
DOLLARS OF THESE RISKS. ARE
DIFFERENT AND COMBINE. ARTIST
SCALE NOT PREVIOUSLY SEEN AND
WILL ASSIST THE INSURANCE
MARKET PLACE TO RESPOND OF. AND
THIS IS WHY I WATCH YOU WANT TO
POINT OUT HAT THIS BILL
PROVIDES THAT IT OUGHT TO BE
ADOPTED AND IMPLEMENTED AS A IN
TY READY. AND CAMPAIGN WITH THE
SENATE BILL WE WILL ALSO SEE
TODAY. AND IT FOR THESE REASONS
THE PROVISIONS ARE ACTUALLY NOT
SEPARABLE. THAT THE TWO BILLS
THEIR PROVISIONS REPRESENTS A-
AN INTEGRATED PACKAGE ON HOW TO
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA CHURCH
MARKET PLACE AND I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT JUST AS WHEN
THEY ADOPTED. THE C. A THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY
AND SET UP THEIR SYSTEM OF RATE
SETTING IT CONCLUDES WITH ALL
RATE SHALL BE APPROVED BY THE
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY USE. THIS
BILL IS NOT AN END RUN AROUND
COMMERCIAL RATE APPROVAL THAT
IS ALSO INCORPORATED IN THIS.
AND TO THE OBJECTION THAT WELL
WE MIGHT HAVE TO RUSH. ALL THE
FIRST COMMERCIAL WILL BE ABLE
TO SEE THE SAME A MARVEL. AND
UNDERSTAND AND THINK THROUGH
ITS RATE IMPLICATIONS. SO EVERY
RATE THAT COMES INTO THIS PLAN
WILL NOT BE A CASE OF FIRST
IMPRESSION I GOTTA FIGURE OUT
ALL THOSE BURIED IN THIS THING.
IT'LL BE FOUNDED UPON THIS
PUBLIC TOOLS SO I ACTUALLY FEEL
THE JUDGMENT THAT WE COULD
SUPPORT. A RATE PROPOSAL ON OR
NINE MAP PLAN TO GET ENSURE
INTO AN AT RISK COUNTY. AND AN
ACCELERATED PROCESS IT'S IS
FOUNDED UPON IS VERY PUBLIC
TOOL. I ACTUALLY FEEL THAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE SORT OF. OURS IN OF
THE WRIST. AND ALLOCATION AND
BURDENS. AND ACTUALLY THE FIRST
PERFECT BUT I THEIR PROCESS.
AND I'VE CHOSEN TO MAKE THESE
REMARKS BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
FEEL. IT IS A VERY WELL FOUNDER
PROPOSAL NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
RESEARCH COVER FOR OF WHICH-
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S ACT
BORDERS RECOGNIZES. MARKET
ASSISTANCE PLANS AS A TOOL TO
GET- YOU CAN FIND IT DISCUSSED
BY THEM IT IS A- IT IS JUST A
TOOL AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
STRUCTURED AS A- GIVEAWAY THE
INDUSTRY ARE ACTUALLY HAS A
WELL BALANCED TO ON BEHALF OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND KNOWLEDGE
IN THE CHANGING TIMES. IN THIS
PERIL FIRE. DAVIS COOLEY WILL
RECOGNIZE DOCTOR WOULD. I GUESS
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR.
THIS MIGHT WORK BETTER- DAVIS
RIGHT YOU'RE JUST I AM A
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY I DO
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR OF FIRST OF ALL- HOW
DOES THIS HOW WILL THIS-
ACTUALLY- PROTECT THOSE WHO
ALREADY HAVE AFFORDABLE%
POLICIES RIGHT NOW- ARE THERE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE BUILT INTO
THAT- AND HOW- HOW WOULD AFFECT
THOSE POLICIES. MR WOULD
BELIEVE FOR THOSE WHO CURRENTLY
ARE INSURED AND HALF POLICIES-
THERE WILL BE- THEY ARE-
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE THERE'S NO.
THERE SHOULD BE NO THE FACT. SO
THERE'S THEY SHOULD NOT SEE THE
NECESSARILY SEE AN INCREASE IN
THEIR POLICY. THEN THE PREMIUMS
WITH THIS WITH THIS SOMEPLACE
IS OUT OF I DON'T ABOUT THE
BEEN DISSIPATED THIS BILL. THAT
THIS NEW- A PROCEDURE- THIS NEW
PLANNING DEVICE. WOULD. WOULD
WE WOULD BEAR THAT RESULT IF IT
IT'S DESIGNED TO. TO MAKE THE
MARKET MECHANISMS IN COUNTIES
IN REGIONS MORE VIBRANT FOR
THOSE INSURERS WHO WHO CHOOSE
NOT NOT TO OFFER INSURANCE.
SOMETIMES THIS WILL GIVE THEM.
A PATH TO DO SO. AND THAT OF MY
FINAL QUESTION WOULD BE HOW DO
WE HOW DO WE KNOW THAT THIS
WILL ACTUALLY STIMULATE- THE
ABILITY FOR VENTURES ACTUALLY
WRITE POLICIES IN THESE AREAS
THAT'S THE GOAL MISTER WOOD IS-
AND BECAUSE CLEARLY THERE IS A-
A BIT OF A CRISIS IN CERTAIN.
HIGH FIRE AREAS OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE INSURERS HAVE PULLED BACK
FROM THE MARKET PLACE- AND THIS
IS DESIGNED TO BE I DON'T WANT
TO. YOU KNOW THE PHRASE CARROT
AND STICK IS OVER USE BUT
THERE'S AN INCENTIVE HERE- FOR
INSURERS TO HAVE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF CERTAINTY- THE
COMMUNITY. INDIVIDUAL
HOMEOWNERS AND THE COMMUNITIES
THEY LIVE AND WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP
MITIGATION STANDARDS. AND
PROTECTIONS FOR EVERYONE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WILL. I DON'T KNOW
HILL DRIVE DOWN COSTS BUT IT'LL
IT'LL GIVE SOME ASSURANCE ON
COSTS. AND THE WHOLE GOAL HERE
IS TO GET INSURERS WHO WERE NOT
WRITING. ENOUGH POLICIES
ENOUGH. POLICIES WE WOULD
DESIRE. GIVE THEM- A REASON TO
ENGAGE. THANK AND I ONE OF-
THANK MISTER COOLEY WHO WAS A
JOINT AUTHOR OF THE BILL FOR
HIS OUTSTANDING- A WALK THROUGH
HISTORY WE CAN LEARN A LOT FROM
THOSE HISTORICAL EXAMPLES. AND
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT MR COOLEY
HAS A COLLECTION OF. THE YEAH
ARTIFACTS THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM WILL WILL HELLO THANK YOU
THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE HAS ANY QUESTIONS
OR- OR- IF NOT THEN MR DAILY
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS AND IT'S IMPORTANT
AGAIN TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS.
MEASURE WILL ONLY GOING TO
AFFECT- AND BECOME LAW IF
SENATOR RUBIO IS BILL WHICH WE
WILL HERE SHORTLY ALSO DOESN'T
ALLOW THEIR COMPANION MEASURES.
AND THEY WORK HAND IN HAND HER
BILL EMPHASIZES THAT THE
MITIGATION STANDARDS IN THAT
COMMUNITY. OF PLANNING THAT
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN SO YOU'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT SOON. I
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE MISS DALY AYE WE DID
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND I.
REMIND ME WHO THE MOST AND
MISS- MISS BIGELOW I MADE A
MOTION HE WAS THE SECOND. IS
THAT YOU GUYS AND- THE SECOND
IS A GRAYSON SECOND I WITH
THAT- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS DAILY. HI DALY
AYE MAYES AYE MAYES. MAYES I
SORRY BIGELOW. A BIGELOW AYE
BERMAN AND HI RIVAS RIVAS HI
GEN GEN HI COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER COOPER I FRAZIER FRAZIER
AYE GIPSON GIPSON HI GRAYSON
GRAYSON ICON LONGER COME LONGER
AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL I WOULD WOOD
HI AT FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN
ZERO ONCE DAILY MEASURE PASSED.
THANK YOU IN FACT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP MR MAYES. YOU DIDN'T
GET TOO CARRIED AWAY WITH THE
GAVEL THAT'S THAT'S A FIRST FOR
YOU YOU KNOW YEAH. AND WE'LL GO
NOW TO OUR NEXT BILL WHICH I
BELIEVE IS MISTER BLOOM. AB.
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX. AND
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED AND WILL WANT TO KIND
OF HIGHLIGHT THAT BECAUSE SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE ISN'T. ISN'T
READY TODAY SO WILL BE. I
FORGET THE LEGAL TERM BUT WILL
HAVE TO ADOPT THOSE AMENDMENTS
AND THEN HAVE THE- HAVE THE
LANGUAGE TO PREPARE ABSOLUTELY
GO AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I AM PLEASED WITH THAT TODAY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY SIX WHICH WOULD HELP
CONSUMERS COMPLY WITH
APPLICABLE BUILDING CODE IN
PLACE AFTER A MAJOR PROPERTY
LOSS. BY PROVIDING BUILDING
CODE UPGRADE COVERAGE TO
HOMEOWNERS TO HELP COVER THE
COST OF BUILDING CODES AT THE
TIME OF LOS. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN-
AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED TO APPLY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE REFERENCED
ON PAGES TWO AND THREE OF THE
ANALYSIS. AND OF COURSE THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL THE AMENDMENTS REMOVE
ALL OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I'M
PLEASED TO SAY. AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY SIX REQUIRES FIRE
POLICIES TO INCLUDE A MINIMUM.
OF 10% OF PRIMARY DWELLING
LIMIT COVERAGE A AS AN
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT AVAILABLE FOR
REPLACEMENT COST OF THE INSURED
STRUCTURE. AT THE TIME OF LOS.
AS WE ARE ALL TO WEAR OUR STATE
SUFFERS FROM SOME OF THE MOST
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES- THAT-
WE'VE EVER SEEN AND THAT THIS
IS OCCURRED JUST IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS. LEAVING
UNFORTUNATELY MANY CALIFORNIANS
WITHOUT HOMES. AND WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE. MANY OF THE
HOMES THAT ARE DESTROYED BY
THESE WILD CARDS ARE ON THE
OLDER SIDE AND ARE NOT UP TO
DATE WITH CURRENT STATE AND
LOCAL BUILDING CODES. THESE
BUILDING CODES LIKELY APPLY TO
THE REBUILD BUT ARE UNLIKELY TO
BE COVERED BY THEIR INSURER.
WHICH LEAVES MANY UNSUSPECTING
HOMEOWNERS FORCED TO PAY OUT OF
POCKET TO COVER THE COST OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THE UPDATED
NEWLY ADDED BUILDING CODES. FOR
REST JEOPARDIZING THE REBUILD
ALTOGETHER- BECAUSE IT'S JUST
SO EXPENSIVE. AND IN SOME CASES
THAT WILL RESULT IN UNWANTED
SALE OF THE PROPERTY. IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY SIX WILL REQUIRE
ALL RESIDENTIAL FIRE WHAT
POLICIES. TO INCLUDE A MINIMUM
OF 10% BUILDING CODE UPGRADE
COVERAGE TO HELP REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF OUT OF POCKET COSTS
THAT CONSUMERS ARE FORCED TO
PAY. THE AMENDMENTS ESTABLISHED
A SIX MONTH DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO PROVIDE
INSURANCE COMPANIES WITH ENOUGH
TIME TO FILE FOR NEW RATES. BUT
THE BILL REQUIRE THOSE INSURERS%
WHO NEED A FILE- WHO NEED TO
FILE A RULE CHANGE OR RATE
APPLICATION. TO DO THAT NO
LATER THAN APRIL FIRST OF
TWENTY ONE. INSURERS CAN THEN
BEGIN ISSUING RENEWING POLICIES
AND COMPLIANCE WITH THIS BILL
WITHIN SEVENTY FIVE DAYS
FOLLOWING THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS PRIOR APPROVAL OF
ACCURATE CHANGE OR RATE
APPLICATION. AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY SIX IS SPONSORED BY
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS MICHAEL MARTINEZ
THE SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM THIS WILL BE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PERSONS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TO SPEAK.
EITHER BY VIDEO. MISTER
MARTINEZ ARE YOU YOU'RE IN THE
VIDEO CONFERENCE IS VERY A ROOM
RIGHT GOOD. YES THANK YOU
MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT INSURANCE.
COMMISSIONER LOT AS THE SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL AND HOW IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MISSION ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AT REALLY WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOAN FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS MEASURE
AND APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COMMITTEE-
CRITICAL TO COME TO A CONSENSUS
WE DO WORK OUT. THAT THE THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS THE STATE IN HIS
THE- UP BILL INTRODUCTION. AND
SO I MAKE THIS. RICH JUST SAY
THAT. COMMISSIONER LAW OF HEADS.
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE- JUST
AFTER THE AFTERMATH OF A MAJOR
PROPERTY LOSS. THE HOMEOWNER
ATTEMPTED TO REBUILD THEIR HOME
A CAN BE FACED WITH THE DISTAL
COST OF COMPLIANCE OF COMPLYING
WITH CURRENT BUILDING CODES
PASSED AFTER THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THE HME. AND SO WHEN HE WAS
GOING UP AND DOWN THE STATE
THESE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES HE
WAS HEARING FROM A LOT OF
HOMEOWNERS THAT WORDS SIMPLY
JUST SHOCKED TO LEARN THAT THE
COVERAGE WON'T HELP PAY FOR THE
REQUIRED UPGRADE IT'S-
INEFFECTIVE I'M A REBEL. AND SO
THIS BILL WILL GO ALL THE WAY
AND LIVE THANK YOU JOHN THE.
THE AUTHOR STAKEHOLDERS. THEIR
THIRTY AND GET US TO THE- TO
THE SENATE. ON THIS BILLS.
THANK YOU AND WE RESPECT
REQUEST I'VE OF. THANK YOU
MISTER MARTINEZ ARE THERE
OTHERS SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. SURE IF I MIGHT-
PROVIDE CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I
WAS JUST AFTER BY STAFF- I WANT
TO BE THAT I'M ACCEPTING THAT
TEN PERCENT. ABOUT SO AS AS THE
AMENDMENT THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM THANK YOU. AT A AND OF
COURSE. GOVERNOR'S ALL RIGHT.
NEVER WANT TO BE WITHOUT A
PROPER. HARD TO COMPETE WITH MR
SCHOOL IN THE PROP IT IS I WANT
TO KNOW WHAT HE WAS DOING MY
COULD. THE. THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE WRITTEN UP IN THE ANALYSIS
AS WELL THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS FOR. MADAME MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY. FOLKS IN THE
QUEUE. DID ANYONE IS SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT
THIS TIME. LOCAL TO THE LINE
NUMBER OF LINES SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO
RESPONSE FOR THE CLOTHING LINE.
MEXICO TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN MY
NUMBER SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GOD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ANNA BUCK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE HAVE A SUPPORT IT'S
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL-
OUR MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE BUILDING- MODIFIED TO- THE
MODEL THAT THE MANDATORY OFFER
EXTENDED COVERAGE AS OPPOSED TO
SIMPLY- A MANDATE FOR THE
POLICY HOLDERS HAVE- MORE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO THEM AT
THE TIME OF PURCHASING THE
POLICY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS BUCK. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE. NO I DON'T
THINK YOU SIR PLEASE CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT. OTHER PERSONS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. EITHER
VIA EMAIL. AS CHAIR SERVER
TAYLOR HERE WITH THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION REALLY
JUST TO SAY THAT THE- THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS ON BEHALF OF PASSED AT ABC
I A YEAH ATTIC- BECAUSE OF THE
CHANGES WE'VE REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION AND YOU TO POSITION
SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE IT RIGHT
WHERE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK. EITHER OPPOSE STORE
NEUTRAL. THAT APPEARS TO COVER
THE TESTIMONY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MR BLOOM ON THIS BILL MR VOEPEL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS- BUT I'M- GOING
TO BE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. AND THE REASON IS. IF YOU
OWN A HOME THAT'S- BEN BUILT
WITHIN EIGHT OR TEN YEARS.
PROBABLY DO NOT NEED THIS
COVERAGE IF YOUR HOME IS OVER
TEN YEARS OF AGE YOU MAY VERY
WELL NEED THIS COVERAGE SO.
THAT ADDRESSES THAT GROUP BUT
THE REASON I'M IN OPPOSITION IS.
IF YOU HAVE AN OLDER HOME OR
YOU LIVE IN A FIRE PRONE
DISTRICT. YOU SHOULD BY THE
RIDER THAT'S WHAT THE THEY CALL
IT A RIDE. IN PAVE THE ACT ONLY.
IN A SENSE IF WE- MANDATE
EVERYONE AT THIS EXTRA 10% WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS YOU'RE TAKING
PEOPLE. THAT DON'T NEED THE
COVERAGE. AND YOU'RE GIVEN A
TO- AND CHARGING HIM FOR IT
WHETHER THEY NEEDED OR NOT SO
IT'S BASICALLY ONE SIZE FITS
ALL ALSO IT'S- HOMES IN SAFE
AREAS. PAY MORE TO SUBSIDIZE
THE HOMES IN UNSAFE AREAS ARE
HIGH FIRE AREA. IF A CONSUMER
WANTS THE EXTRA COVERAGE FOR
THE CODE PROTECTION. THEY CAN
PAY FOR IT. SO THAT'S MY BASIC
POSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR. THANK YOU. MR BLOOM WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO THE
COMMENTS I GREW UP KIND OF
MISTER MARTINEZ- MIGHT BE- AND
BETTER POSITION TO. PROVIDE
COMMENTS TO THE RIGHT IN
RESPONSE. MISTER MARTINEZ IN
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO THE
POINT. IT'S MADE ABOUT THE
SUBSIDY THAT MAY BE INVOLVED.
WITH A MCCARTY THIS YEAR ON FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
SELECT TO SAY THAT AT LEAST IN
PROVIDING US THE THIS COVERAGE
THAT WOULD BE. GENERAL PROVIDER
COSTS THE BOARD IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WAS OF KEEN INTEREST IN IN
HEARING FROM A VARIETY OF
POLICYHOLDERS WHO WERE
AFFECTED. IN SO AT THIS POINT
IT IS IT SOMETHING THAT IS- IT
WOULD BE A GOOD BENEFIT THE
BENEFITS OF THE CONSUMERS AND
PROVIDER AN INFORMED CONSUMER
PROTECTION- OF CONSUMERS
ESPECIALLY GIVEN. WITH THE
WEARING OF UNEMPLOYMENT SO THAT
WE PROVIDED TO MAKE THE BILL
WORKABLE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
TO THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR MISTER BLOOM. IF
NOT MISTER BLOOM YOU'RE WELCOME
TO WRAP UP AND WILL VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I'VE A
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS. THANK
YOU THIS SERVE BILL HAS A- AND
I RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR- WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT
BEEN AGREED TO. THERE WAS A
MOTION AND SECOND. MR COOLEY IS
THERE A SECOND TO MISTER COOL.
WELL THAT'S RIGHT YOU DID THAT
EARLY. SO WE HAVE A LOT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS OF ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED DALY AYE
DALY AYE MAYES MAYES AYE BERMAN
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW HI
RIVAS RIVAS ALL RIGHT CHEN.
CHEN HI COOLEY COOLEY AYE
COOPER UBER I FRAZIER FRAZIER
AYE GIPSON GIPSON HI GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE COM LONGER KAMLAGER
I VOEPEL. VOEPEL NO ONE WOULD
WHAT HI THAT'S THIRTEEN TO ONE
THE BILL PASSES. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM. AND I THINK MISS
LOW MOAN IS NEXT. WITH AB.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX. HERE
YOU ARE WELCOME TO OUR HEARING
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR AND-
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE HO HAS BEEN INVOLVED
IN THE BILL STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CONSUMER
PROTECTION. FOR DIFFERENT THINK
CONDITIONS POLICIES ISSUED OR
RENEWED. WE HAVE WORKED WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND COMMON
GROUND AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THIS CONVERSATION TO
ENSURE CONSUMERS ARE AWARE WHEN
COVERAGE IS CHANGE- ELIMINATED
FROM A POLICY. I INTRODUCED AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX BECAUSE
OF ITS IMPORTANCE TO
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE WHO
EXPERIENCE WILDFIRES YEAR AFTER
YEAR. FOR OVER TWO YEARS NOW I
HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM
CONSTITUENTS WHO THOUGHT THEY
HAD COVERAGE. SAY THAT WHEN
THEY WENT TO THEIR SURE THEY
REALIZE THAT THEY DID NOT HAVE
THE COVERAGE THEY THOUGHT.
SEVEN FIFTY SIX WE'LL MAKE SURE
THE AND THE LIMITATION OF
COVERAGE IS CLEARED TO A
HOMEOWNER. I AM COMMITTED TO
REDUCING THE SCOPE OF SECTION
ONE. SO THAT IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE A NON RENEWAL AND A NEW
POLICY TO BE ISSUED. AND TO
FURTHER CLARIFY THE DISCLOSURE
LANGUAGE FIRED ON THE NOTICE
STATEMENT. I'M ACCEPTING AND
DRAFTED AMENDMENT IN ORDER TO
WORK WITH HOLDERS AND- EIGHTY.
FINDING RIGHT FRAME TO GET
ASSIGNED TECHNOLOGY. MANAGEMENT
FORM THAT. FROM A CONSUMER
THESE COMMITMENTS ARE ON TOP OF
PREVIOUSLY AGREED AMENDMENTS
THAT THE LADY IMPLEMENTATION
AND NEAR THE SCHOOL THE BILL.
SO THAT IT. IS ONLY REQUIRED
WHEN YOU WERE RIGHT. POLICY IS
NOT FIRE COVERAGE. WITH ME TO
ARE HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS MICHAEL
MARTINEZ. SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER WE GOT A LOT AT.
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. IS OUR SECOND
GOOD THANK YOU SIR. GO AHEAD
MISTER MARTINEZ. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PART OF
INSURANCE AND SHE AND FOR
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA. COMMISSIONER LARA IS THE
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY SIX AND GET ONE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF LIMON FOR
HER LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING
THIS. CONSUMER PROTECTION
MEASURE. COMMISSION WATER
SPONSORING THIS IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTION MEASURE
BECAUSE WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE HOMEOWNER KNOWS
UP FRONT AND PROMINENTLY
DISCLOSED WHAT'S EXACTLY IN A
HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE POLICY.
AND WHAT ISN'T AND WHAT
COVERAGES ARE REDUCED OR
ELIMINATED BY INSURANCE COMPANY
WHEN A POLICY IS RENEWED.
BECAUSE WHEN IT'S DONE THE PAST
FEW YEARS OF THE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES AS HE IN THE
DEPARTMENT WENT UP AND DOWN THE
STATE WE DID RECEIVE NUMEROUS
COMPLAINTS FROM MANY CONSUMER
SURGING THAT. THEY DID NOT KNOW
THEIR POLICY DOES NOT COVER THE
PERIL FIRE WHEN AT SOME
PREVIOUS POINT POLICY MAY HAVE
COVER POLICY OF FIRE. UP THE
PERIL OF FIRE AND SERVICES
THIS. REALLY DISCLOSURE
APPRENTICE LOSURE BILL- IS
IMPORTANT AND NOT. AND I DO
WANT TO ALSO KNOWLEDGE ALL OF
THE STATE. OUR TO ADDRESS THE
TWO. FROM INDUSTRY COMMITTEE
STAFF. AND EVERYONE SUPPORT OF
THEIR. JUST PARTICIPATION AND
THAT AFTER. AND WITHOUT WITH
RIGHT UP THANK YOU. ARE THERE
OTHER WISHING STE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BY. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
VIDEO ROOM. IF NOT TO THE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR DO YOU
HAVE ANYONE IN YOUR QUEUE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR. YES ANOTHER
REMINDER IF YOU'RE IN FAVOR TO
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
WILL GO TO THE LINE OF NUMBER
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I CANNOT BASS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE'RE STILL EVALUATING
OUR POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT-
WE WANTED TO TAKE THE TIME TO
THANK THE- MEMBER AND THE
DEPARTMENT. OF INSURANCE FOR
THEIR- WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
FEATURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS BOX IN THE OTHER PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
ANYONE ELSE AND NO ONE ON
EITHER ON THE PHONE LINES AT
THE TIME THERE OKAY OTHER ANY
PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
AGAINST THE BILL. VIDEO ROOM.
AFTERNOON AGAIN OFFICE CHAIRS
ARE TAYLOR HERE FOR THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION
JUST AGAIN TO ON BEHALF OF HAVE
HAD A CANDY PCI A TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE CONSTRUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS AND BELIEVE THAT
WITH THE AUTHORS OF WHAT THE
AUTHORS COMMITTED TO- WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE SO AGAIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR
ANY OTHER PERSON'S SO. NEUTRAL
OR OPPOSED. IN THE VIDEO ROOM.
IF NOT. ARE THERE ANY PERSONS
IN THE TELEPHONE QUEUE LINE
GUESS THAT'S REDUNDANT
TELEPHONE Q. NOT WANTING TO AT
THE TIME SIR. OKAY. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR MISS LIMóN. THIS
LIMóN GO AHEAD RAPPER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THIS BILL HAS OF THE
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION OF
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
THOSE AMENDMENTS MISS LAMONT.
AND LET'S GO TO A ROLL CALL
VOTE. THE VOTE THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED DALY AYE DALY
AYE MAYES MAYES AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW HI
RIVAS. RIVAS I CHAN. CHAN I
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE COOPER
COOPER I FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
GIPSON GIPSON HI GRAYSON
GRAYSON HI KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
VOEPEL VOEPEL I WOULD WOOD HI
THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO. FOURTEEN
ZERO PRETTY WELL DONE MISSILE
MON OKAY. MISTER WOODS UP NEXT.
AB THREE ZERO ONE TWO AND THEN
THERE'S ONE ADDITIONAL BILL.
AFTER MR WOOD BY SENATOR RUBIO
GO AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- IN OCTOBER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE TUBS FIRE
CHANGE MY HOME TOWN OF SANTA
ROSA FOREVER. THE FIRE
DESTROYED 500-060-0403
STRUCTURES TOOK THE LIVES OF
TWENTY TWO PEOPLE. NEARLY ALL
OF THEM WERE FROM COMMUNITIES I
REPRESENT SEND SEND MY STAFF
AND I HAVE SPENT COUNTLESS
HOURS WORKING WITH CONSTITUENTS
AND THEIR INSURANCE COMPANIES
YOU IN OUR BEST TO HELP
CONSTITUENTS GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET. TWO AND A HALF YEARS
LATER AND YOU CAN SEE THE
REBUILDING PROCESS UNDER WAY
ALL OVER CINEMA COUNTY. WE
LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
INCLUDING HOW ILL PREPARED WE
WERE FOR THIS NEW ABNORMAL.
NOBODY PLANS FOR FIRE TORNADOES
OR WILD FIRES THAT BURNED SO
FAST AND SO HOT THAT THEY
JUMPED EIGHT LANES OF FREEWAY.
AND TURNED CAR WHEELS MOLTEN
METAL. NOT EVEN INSURANCE
COMPANIES PLAN FOR THAT KIND OF
DEVASTATION. WE'VE BEEN
WRESTLING WITH THE AFTERMATH
EVER SINCE. AB THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND AND TWELVE IS NOT A
SILVER BULLET BUT I THINK IT'S
A SERIES OF BALANCE STEPS IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. THE BILL
DOES FIVE THINGS. IT BUILDS ON
THE HOME INSURANCE BINDER THAT
MY BILL EIGHT TEAMS AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. HELP CONNECT
HOMEOWNERS WITH COMPANIES THAT
MAY NOT HAVE BIG ADVERTISING
BUDGETS BUT MAY BE WILLING TO
OFFER HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE
WHERE OTHERS ARE NOT. IT
PROHIBITS INSURERS FROM
DETECTING THE VALUE OF THE LAND
VALUE OF THE PROPERTY IF THE
HOMEOWNER CHOOSES TO REBUILD OR
BUY A HOME SOMEWHERE ELSE. IT
SAYS THAT A HOME. APRIL HOME IS
LOST DURING A DECLARED DISASTER
INSURERS MUST OFFER A 30% OF
THE DWELLING COVERAGE LIMITS UP
TO TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. WITH NO ITEM
IS ATION REQUIRED. REQUIRES
INSURERS TO CONTINUE PAYING
ADDITIONAL LIVING EXPENSES IF
THE HOME IS REBUILT BUT NOT YET
INHABITABLE TO DO IN AN
INSUFFICIENT INFRASTRUCTURE.
SUCH AS THE WATER SYSTEM AT
THAT IS STILL DOWN FOR THE
ELECTRIC RIP THAT HASN'T BEEN
REPLACED AND THAT IS A REALITY
IN MY DISTRICT. FINALLY AB
THREE THREE ZERO ONE TWO
REQUIRES THE FAIR PLAN TO
CREATE A CLEARING HOUSE TO HELP
INSURERS GET HOMEOWNERS OFF OF
THE VERY EXPENSIVE FAIR PLAN.
BUT THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR EYE BUT- THANK YOU MISTER
WOULD. ARE THERE PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR. WHAT
WAS THAT MARK. MEN SORRY YEAH
I'VE I APOLOGIZE- I AM
ACCEPTING PROPOSED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M SORRY. THANK YOU
WOULD. YES. HI YEAH LET'S GIVE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PERSONS IN
THE VIDEO ROOM TO. SUPPORT THE
BILL ATTORNEY PERSONS THERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY
COLLECTION IS HERE ON BEHALF OF
IN SEARCH DURING SPECIAL KERR
LARA IN CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE ALTHOUGH WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THIS MEASURE YET- WE DO
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THE
INTENT OF THE BILL THERE'S
ACTUALLY SEVERAL COMPONENTS. IN
THIS MEASURE THAT- ARE ALSO
CONTAINED IN THEM A SIMILAR
BILL OF THAT COMMISSION A LOT
OF SPONSORING- SENATE BILL
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO AND SO WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL AND
HEALTHCARE- IS THE BURDEN FOR
THOSE CONSUMERS ATTEMPTING TO
REBUILD THEIR HOME AND I SAID
AFTER A CATASTROPHIC DISASTER.
IN TO POTENTIAL OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE AS NOTED IN THE
TRADING ELSE'S I DO WANT TO SAY
AT LEAST FOR THE COMMITTEES-
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
INFORMATION THAT. THE
DEPARTMENT HAD PREVIOUSLY
ISSUED EMERGENCY NOTICES IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
FOR WILDFIRES THAT CALLED ON
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO.
EXPEDITE CLAIMS THAT WOULD MAKE
IT INITIAL ADVANCE PAYMENTS FOR
PERSONAL PROPERTY ADVANCED
DAILY PAYMENTS I REDUCE OVERLY
ONEROUS ITEMS ATION OF THE
HOMEOWNERS PERSONAL CONTENTS-
DURING THOSE. A FEW- YEARS OF
TIME AND WHEN WE HAD SENT OUT
THOSE EMERGENCY NOTICES.
VIRTUALLY ALL INSURANCE
COMPANIES AGREES TO THOSE
ACTIONS- THE REQUEST BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE FOR
THEIR POLICY HOLDER SO WE DO
SORT OF QUESTION WHY SOME IN
OUR INDUSTRY MAY HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THOSE ELEMENTS. THAT ARE
INCORPORATED IN THIS BILL NOW
WOULD YOU LOOK FOR WORKING WITH
AUTHORS ON THIS- AND WHICH
INCLUDES SOME TECHNICAL
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE- AND
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THE
CONTENTS COVERAGE PAYMENT
AMOUNTS. TO ENSURE THE CURRENT
FORMULA AS JACK THE BILL DOES
NOT CREATE. AN INCENTIVE-
CONSEQUENCES INEQUITIES AND
OTHERWISE LIMIT THE BENEFIT OF
OTHERWISE THIS. CONSUMER
PROTECTION CHAU SO WITH THAT
SAID WE DO I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO COLLABORATE WITH
THE INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS AS
THIS. BILL MOVES. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER PERSONS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
ANYONE IN THE VIDEO ROOM. AND
IF NOT IN THE VIDEO ROOM HOW
ABOUT VIA TELEPHONE. MISS
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE. YES SIR I DO HAVE
SOMEONE IN A CUBICLE THE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO THE I POD I
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SEVENTY
ONE. GO AHEAD WE CAN HEAR YOU
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OR ARE THE
RAIDERS AND I CAN'T FIND A
LOCAL. YES SEVERAL CAROLINA
THIRTY TO NINE THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS-
SUPERVISOR AT SCHOOL FIELD IN
NEVADA COUNTY AM I SPEAKING.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU SIR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION GO
AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I AM A DISTRICT TO A SUPERVISOR
TO THAT A COUNTY I'VE SEARCHED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND NINE.
AND I KNOW- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FIRED TODAY AND ASSEMBLY- A
MEMBER WOULD PROBABLY KNOWS
MORE ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND
INSURANCE AND- CONSEQUENCES
THAT THE BUYERS- MORE THAN
ANYONE AND IN FACT- WE'VE
CALLED FOLLOWED VERY CLOSELY.
SONOMA AND SOME OF THE REFORMS
THAT WE'VE SEEN DOWN THERE AND
WE FOLLOW THE INSURANCE ISSUE.
THANK YOU SIR FOR YOUR COMMENT.
ARE THERE OTHER FOLKS IN THE
QUEUE. YES SIR THERE ARE LOCAL
LINE NUMBER FIFTY ONE ONE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF GOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAY BE A GLITCH THERE
MISS MODERATOR. YES SIR. WANT
TO TRY THAT ONE AGAIN. YES
THERE. MY FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR US. ONE
FIFTY ONE. HELLO THERE THE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MAYBE SHE
CHANGED HER MIND MISTER WOULD.
WELL MISS MODERATOR MAYBE WE'LL
TRY THAT ONE ONE MORE TIME BUT
LET'S SEE WHO ELSE IS OR ANYONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS POINT.
THERE WE DO HAVE ONE FIFTY ONE
NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS
FOR THAT FEEDBACK. AGAIN I'M
THAT THE YOUNG MAN. BARBARA
COUNTY SUPERVISOR. TO THIRTY
FIVE. REPRESENTS THE AREA FROM
FEAR OF FOOTHILL ALL THE WAY UP
THROUGH THE ALL OF. THE
COMMUNITIES OF AUBURN COLFAX.
THE JUDGE FLAT. NORTH START
BALLET AND LAKE TAHOE. WE
SUPPORT THIS. BILL IT'S A
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO HELP
HOMEOWNERS. DURING TIMES OF. AS
WELL AS AFTER WHERE TIMELINE
FOR THE DEADLINE ARE OUT OF OUR
CONTROL. COUNTIES NOW WITH A
FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME BEFORE I
START ACTING LIKE THEM FUN. TO
THE INABILITY TO SPELL HOME.
AND DID THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
INSURANCE COVER. WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE THIS BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THE TIME. TO ME I
HAVE BEEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF
THE- YOUR CONSTITUENTS IN
PLASTER COUNTY WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER FOLKS IN THE IN THE
QUEUE. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
ISSUE AT THIS TIME SIR PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ARE THERE ANY FORK
SIR IN THE VIDEO ROOM WHO WISH
TO OPPOSE THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR SIR
TAYLOR OF THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION YOU KNOW
ALL THE PROVISIONS THAT
ESTABLISH THE FAIR PLAYING
CLEARING HOUSE AND HAD A NOTICE
THAT PROVIDES MORE INFORMATION
ON HOW TO ACCESS THE FAIR PLAN.
ARE SUPPORTABLE WE
UNFORTUNATELY STILL MUST
OPPOSED AB THIRTY TWELVE YOU
KNOW WE CONTINUE TO HEAR
ONGOING CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AFFORDABILITY OF HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL WILL EXACERBATE
PROBLEMS. SPECIFICALLY BY
EXPANDING THE CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDER WHICH CONDITIONS LIVING
EXPENSES PAYMENTS ARE REQUIRED.
USING THE LEVEL OF SCRUTINY FOR
CONTENT GAINES ULTIMATELY THIS
MEASURE WILL DRIVE UP INSURANCE
COSTS FOR CALIFORNIA. AND FOR
THAT REASON WE CONTINUE TO
FOCUS. THANK YOU. I THINK THANK
YOU SIR OTHER OTHER FOLKS IN
THE VIDEO ROOM WHICH TO OPPOSE
THE BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY
MCCUE REPRESENTING THE PACIFIC
ASSOCIATION DOMESTIC INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND ALSO SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS
ASSOCIATION. ATTIC AND A P. C.
I. A. ARE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW AB THIRTY TWELVE COULD
IMPACT THE AFFORDABILITY OF
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE. HOWEVER
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT SOME OF
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS ARE
NEEDED TO HELP CLARIFY THE
ORIGINAL TENS OF THESE OF THE
STATUTE. WITH THAT BEING SAID
WOULD REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL IF WE COULD ESTABLISH
THE CALIFORNIA HOME INSURANCE
FINDER NOTICE IN STATUTE AND IF
WE COULD PROVIDE A LITTLE
CLARITY AS THE PROVISIONS
PERTAIN TO THE LAND DEDUCTION
VALUE. AND THE DAILY ISSUES WE
ARE HOPEFUL THE CONVERSATIONS
AN ONGOING CONVERSATION IS WITH
THE OPS OFFICE WILL REDUCE WILL
RESULT IN HE WOULD NOT. AND
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WILL BE A
NEUTRAL ON THEM BY THE TIME IT
REACHES THE- FLOOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MS MCCUE.
WHETHER OTHER PERSONS IN THE
VIDEO ROOM. EITHER NEUTRAL OR
OPPOSED. IF NOT LET'S GO TO THE
MODERATOR FOR THE PHONE LINES
ARE THERE ANY PERSONS IN THE IN
LINE. HEY WE COULD HAVE A FEW
WILL GO BACK TO LINE THIRTY TWO
THREE CAN FINISH HAS THAT AND
HIS RESPONSE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN FOR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GO AHEAD SIR. THE
SUPERVISOR- AT SCHOFIELD FROM-
NEVADA COUNTY. HOW DO YOU GET
STARTED ON THIS. GENTLEMAN I
APOLOGIZE- I JUST WANT TO
SUMMARIZE BY SAYING I THINK
THAT. THIS BILL. NOT ONLY. GOES
TO PROTECTION OF THE CONSUMERS
AND MY CONSTITUENTS BUT ALSO.
RECOGNIZES TO THE EXTREME
CONCERNS AT THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY. SO ON BEHALF OF MY
DISTRICT IN NEVADA COUNTY I
WANT TO GIVE- TOTAL SUPPORT TO
THIS BILL. AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR. THANK YOU SUPERVISOR
SCHOFIELD. SORRY FOR THE
PREVIOUS GLITCH ON THE LINE.
OTHER OTHER FOLKS I THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU. YES A RECORDER
LINE FIFTY SEVEN ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
BUDGET. GARY YES YEAH WE GO
AHEAD. OUR MONTHLY UP WITH MATT
LETTER THAT THE F. PLAN. BY THE
PEP BAND THE POSITION OF THE
OTHER PROVISIONS IF YOU THIRTY
WHILE WE DO SUPPORT THE BOTTOM
THAT. REQUIRING NON NOT A
PROVIDE INFORMATION AND BY THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE UNDER THEIR
PLAN. BABBAGE'S WEARING OUT
ALLOWING IT DEVELOPED THERE YET
BOTH AND WILL HELP WALK IN THE
PRIVATE MARKET. AND COULD
RESULT IN LESS. THAN OF THE
DIFFICULT AND- IN THE LONG RUN
IT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL FOR A
CONSUMER. THAT IT WILL GIVE
THEM A áP BACK. TO THE PRIVATE
MARKET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY ONE YES- ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS STACEY HIDDEN
FROM THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND I GOODS TO LITTLE BIT
EARLIER BUT I'M ACTUALLY
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE. AFTER WE HAVE MY
NUMBER SIXTY THREE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN PEOPLE HAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON ANA BUT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- OUR MEMBERSHIP AGAIN
IT'S STILL EVALUATING THE-
MEASURE AS WELL. THAT WE WANTED
TO AGAIN TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO EXTEND OUR THANKS TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ON AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
ON- THE IMPORTANT ISSUE OF FIRE
INSURANCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MS BOOK. ANY OTHER PERSONS
PARTICIPATING VIA TELEPHONE.
AND AS A REMINDER TO ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY NO ONE ELSE
COULD USE OUR PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS MISTER BIGELOW. TO
THE AUTHOR- THIS MCCUE RAISED A
VALID POINT THERE JUST A
COMMITMENT FROM YOU ARE YOU
WILLING ARE. ABLE TO LOOK AT
MAKING AN AMENDMENT. OR FOR
THEIR ADDRESSING HER CONCERNS-
IN CLARITY FOR MEETING THOSE
NEEDS. I'VE I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH EVERYONE
I MY DOOR IS ALWAYS OPEN- I
WILL SAY- IN IN RESPECT TO THE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED
NUMBER ONE- THE- ADDITIONAL
LIVING EXPENSES- HOW IS IT HOW
IS IT FAIR TO THE CONSUMER WHO
LOST EVERYTHING. NOW TO HAVE
WATER MAYBE DOESN'T HAVE POWER.
CAN'T MOVE INTO THEIR HOUSE
BECAUSE A COUNTY OR CITY WON'T
ISSUE OF A- AN OCCUPANCY PERMIT
HOW IS THAT FAIR AND- AND SO IF
I'M IF THE OPPOSITION HAS
ANOTHER ALL OF THEIR OF THEIR
LOVE TO LOVE TO LOVE TO. BUT
BUT YOU ARE FROM LOS AND
EVERYTHING YOU CAN IS NOT YOUR
FAULT THAT YOU DON'T HAVE POWER
YOU MAY DON'T HAVE WATER- AND
SO I'M I'M OPEN TO ALTERNATIVES
THERE AS FAR AS THE ITEM IS
ATION REQUIREMENT. CATASTROPHIC
LOSS YOU'VE LOST EVERYTHING
INSURANCE COME IS GOING TO PAY
IT OUT WE'RE GONNA PAY OUT A
100% AT SOME POINT. WE REALLY
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE ITEMIZE IN
EVERYTHING- WHICH THEY PROBABLY
WON'T BE ABLE TO DO ANYWAY
BECAUSE ALL THE RECEIPTS ARE
GONE AS WELL SO IT'S NOT
ADDITIONAL COVERAGE IT IS JUST
AN ADVANCE ON ON WHAT IS GOING
TO BE TO THEM AND IT'S UP TO
THE HOMEOWNER TO DECIDE OKAY
AND I AM I I'VE I'VE TAKEN THIS
MAYBE I'M GONNA HAVE TO SET UP
SET SET ASIDE SOME OF THAT FOR
THE REBUILD BUT- IT IS IT IS-
IT IS REALLY MEANT TO GIVE THE
HOMEOWNER A HEAD START. ON A
REALLY PAINFUL RECOVERY PROCESS.
I THANK YOU FOR THAT RESPONSE I
THINK THAT THE ISSUE THAT. ON
ON THE WRITER PORTION OF IT. WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THAT WITHIN OUR
HOMES EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE FIRE
INSURANCE. YOU HAVE TO GET A
SEPARATE WRITER FOR YOUR
VALUABLES. AND IT CAN BE
EVERYTHING FROM YOUR JEWELRY TO
CERTAIN. MEMORABILIA IS TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS AND THOSE
AREN'T COVERED UNDER THE
STANDARD. OF POLICY UNDER THE
FIRE INSURANCE THEY HAVE TO BE
COVERED SEPARATELY BECAUSE
THEY'RE INVESTMENT- SEPARATE
FROM YOUR HOME- SO I. I SEE THE
CLARITY THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
EXPRESS. WITHIN THE BILL HERE
AND I APPRECIATE THAT. I
APPRECIATE ESPECIALLY THE
COMPONENT BECAUSE YOU AND I
BOTH HAVE. DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
SUFFERED GREATLY WITH ERRORS OF
SUCH MAGNITUDE. NO ONE WOULD
HAVE EVER HAPPENED- BUT THE
REALITIES ARE. PEOPLE CAN'T
MOVE BACK INTO THEIR HOME
WHETHER THEY'RE ON A WATER
SYSTEM SUCH AS- THE COMMUNITY
OF PARADISE. THE LONG BEEN
WANTING TO GET BACK. THERE OKAY
HOMES IN THE BILL IF YOU DON'T
WATER SYSTEM. CAPABLE OF STILLS
PROVIDING A SECURE WATER SYSTEM
WATER LEVEL- MANY PEOPLE WITH.
WELL CAN GET BACK TO THEIR
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN DEVASTATED
NEVER A WATER SYSTEM CAN GAIN
CAN GET RECERTIFIED SO THERE IS
A NUMBER OF ISSUES THERE SO I
AGREE WITH YOU AND I. FEEL
SYMPATHETIC AND- ALMOST. I
WOULD SAY WILLING TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL- WITH YOU TODAY BASED
ON. WHAT I THINK I HEAR IS AN
OPENNESS TO WORKING TO TRY TO
RESOLVE THOSE LAST LITTLE
REMAINING- BITS OF IT OF
CLARITY. THAT AND I WOULD JUST
ADD THAT- THERE THE PROVISION
IN THERE THAT WOULD ALLOW A
HOMEOWNER TO BUILD IN AN
ALTERNATE LOCATION SUCH AS
SOMEONE MAYBE IN PARADISE. OR
IN MCKINLEY- OR OR SOME OF THE
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
DEVASTATED AND THE CAMPFIRE-
WITHOUT A PENALTY OF BEING
HAVING TO. HAVE ANY INSURANCE
COMMITTED DUCKED THE VALUE OF
THE LAND- IS ANOTHER PART IS
ANOTHER PROVISION IN THERE THAT
I FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT.
THANK YOU AND I AT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR LINE TO ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARITY ON THAT WITH
RESPECT TO THE DEDUCTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ARE THERE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR. ALL RIGHT AND- MISTER
WOULD DISOBEY THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WRAP UP JUST I WANT TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL
ABSOLUTELY DO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS I'M OPEN TO WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
OUR MOTION SECOND ON THE BILL.
MR MAYES MOTIONED. THERE'S A
SECOND MISTER FRAZIER. A MISTER
WOULD THE YOUR DISTRICT TO HAS
BEEN THROUGH A- AN ORDEAL THAT
IS A REALLY UNBELIEVABLE. IN
ITS DEVASTATION AND YOU
PERSONALLY HAVE A HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY ACTIVE IN YOUR
DISTRICT. TRY TO HELP FOLKS
SURVIVE AND- AND REBUILD AND
RECOVER SO I KNOW THAT THIS
BILL IS HEARTFELT FOR YOU AND-
IT'S BEEN BILL AND- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENTS TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND- MAKE
IT THE BILL EVEN BETTER.
POSSIBLE TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER WOULD IN THIS TO BE A
ROLL CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED DALY AYE
DALY AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE
BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE RIVAS. RIVAS I CHEN.
CHEN AYE COOLEY COOLEY AYE
COOPER COOPER AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE SOME. GIPSON GIPSON
R. I. GRAYSON GRAYSON HI
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING WOULD WHAT I.
THIRTEEN ZERO. BILL PASSES
THIRTEEN ZERO WITH ONE
ABSTENTION. IN THE LAST THE
BILL ON THE DOCKET TODAY IS
SENATOR RUBIO'S BILL IS SHE- IN
THE HOUSE SO SHE'S OKAY. GOOD
WELCOME. WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER THANK YOU I
HOPE YOU GUYS CAN HEAR ME. WE
CAN YOU'VE ALREADY GOT MOTION
AND SECOND IN. FOR YOUR BILL
THE CHAIR RECOMMEND SUPPORT
MISTER COOLEY REFERENCE YOUR
BILL PREVIOUSLY. AND SO YOU'RE
OFF TO A GREAT START PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS
TODAY ARE PRETENDING MY BILL
THE WILD VIRUS MODELING AND
MEDICATION BELL AS WE KNOW ALL
FIRE SEASON HAS DRAMATICALLY
CHANGED AND IT'S NOW EIGHTY
DAYS LONGER. THAN IT WAS IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES CLEARLY
INCREASING THE RISK OF
UNCONTROLLABLE SEVERE WILDFIRES
THAT ENDANGER LIFE AND
PROPERTY. IN ADDITION CLIMATE
CHANGE AS WELL AS POPULATION
GROWTH AND THE MOVEMENT TO THE
WE HAVE AMPLE AMPLIFIED THE
REST. IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT A- TO A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
REPORTS. ON THE AVAILABILITY
AND AFFORDABILITY A WILDFIRE
COVERAGE PREMIUMS ARE
INCREASING. AND MOST INSURERS
DO NOT TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
WILDFIRE MEDICATION CONDUCTED
BY HOMEOWNERS. HOMEOWNER SHOULD
BE ABLE TO REAP THE REWARDS OF
THEIR WORK AND BETTER DATA OUT
HOME PARTING IS NEEDED TO GET
THEM DONE. THE CREDIT THEY
DESERVE. THE DEPARTMENT FURTHER
STATE THAT A CREDIBLE DATABASE
FOR WELL KERR LOS EXPERIENCE IS
NEEDED AND SUGGEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. SHOULD CREATE A
FRAMEWORK WHERE INSURERS OFFER
MEDICATION PREMIUM CREDIT. FOR
PROPERTY OWNERS THAT DO THEIR
PART. THAT IS WHY SB TWO NINETY
TWO IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
FIRST IT CONTAINS THE TRIGGER
FOR DETERMINING WHEN. AND WHICH
COUNTIES ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
AYE MAP PROGRAM. ELIGIBILITY IS
TO ACCOUNT FOR POPULATION
DENSITY DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
URBAN AND RURAL COUNTY AND USES
THE TWENTY NINETEEN THIRD FOR
PAN NEW BUSINESS AS A TEMPLATE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR INITIAL
AYE MAPPILA DEBILITY SB TWO
NINETY TWO IS RETRACTED SO THE
KILLINGS HIT HARDEST BY NON
RENEWALS AND TWENTY NINETEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY ARE INCLUDED.
SECOND SB TWO NINETY THREE
PARTY OFFICE OF PLANNING A
RESEARCH TO EVALUATE THE AYE
MAP PROGRAM WHICH AIMS TO GROW
THE VOLUNTARY INSURANCE MARKET.
IN THE COUNTY FOR THE VOLUNTARY
MARKET HOUSEHOLD OUT. IN ORDER
TO HOLD ENSURE THE COUNTABLE AT
THREE TO NINETY TWO REQUIRES
FULL PR IMPACT REVIEW OF THE
PROGRAM. AND THIS BRINGS ME TO
MY FINAL AND MOST IMPORTANT
PIECE OF TWO NINETY TWO. SB TWO
NINETY TWO STATE THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONVENE A
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP
INDIVIDUAL HOLDING COMMUNITY
HARDENING STANDARD. UNIFORMITY
CATION STANDARDS WILL PREDICT
WHAT. WILL BE CRITICAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF THE AYE MAP PROGRAM.
AND TO HOMEOWNERS LOOKING FOR
THE BILL'S COST EFFECTIVE FIRE
SAFE RENOVATION AND DEVELOP THE
DATA. NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
ACTUALLY FOUND. MEDICATION
DISCOUNTS FOR HOMEOWNERS. BY
NINETEEN. SB TWO NINETY TWO
WOULD ENCOURAGE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
BETTER SERVE THE NEEDS OF
CONSUMERS. THIS MEANS THAT TE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
HAS CONVENE AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT INCLUDES EXPERT.
FROM THE INDUSTRY AND THE UC
SYSTEM TO DEVELOP STANDARDS BY
USING MODELING AND REYES MAKING
AND A PLAN TO DEVELOP A PUBLIC
LAST MODEL. IF THIS DAMAGE THIS
MODEL WILL BE BE A PUBLIC TOOL
TO PROTECT HOMEOWNERS. FOR
MEMBERS STUDY DEVELOPING AN
INCENTIVIZING HOMEOWNERS TO
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE IN
ACTUALLY SOUND WILDFIRE
MITIGATION MEASURES IT'S
BASICALLY PRUDENT POLICY. WHERE
THE POTENTIAL TO SAVE LIVES AND
PREVENT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
FUTURE LOSSES FROM OCCURRING I
WANT TO ASSURE THE COMMITTEE
HERE TODAY THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE COMMISSIONER
AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS ASKED THE
BILL TO BAN FISTS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE I. THINK
YOU. THANK YOU MISSED RUBIO
LET'S SERVE INVITE ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE PUBLIC- WERE
INTERESTED PARTIES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THERE IS AFTERNOON
CHAIRS FROM THE VIDEO ROOM. YES
SIR GOOD AFTERNOON SIR TAYLOR
AGAIN AS YOU NOTED- I OFFER
COMMENTS EARLIER THAT REFER TO
BOTH AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN
AND SB TWO NINETY TWO BECAUSE
THEY THEY MUST BE ENACTED
JOINTLY BECOME OPERATIVE AND SO
WE VIEW THEM AS A PACKAGE SO I
WON'T REITERATE THOSE COMMENTS.
I WILL SAY AGAIN THAT HAVE
SUPPORTS BOTH BILLS ALONG WITH
THE AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALLY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION AND THE
PACIFIC ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND AGAIN
TO OUR CENTER RUBIO'S POINT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS COMPONENT DOES
HAVE THE FRAMEWORK FOR YOU STAY
COMMISSION. THAT HAS A BROAD
GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT
WOULD DEVELOP HOME COMMUNITY
HARDING STANDARDS THAT CAN
REDUCE LOSS TO DO WILD FIRES
AND ESTABLISH A CENTRAL
DATABASE OF HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE SPECIFIC WALL
VIRUS THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL
TOWARDS THE FUTURE OF LOOKING
THE FUTURE OF REDUCING RISK OF
LOS THAT WILL ALSO HELP BRING
DOWN- INSURANCE. I IT ALSO I
AND AGAIN THE REFERENCE THIS
THE REPORT THE TO BUILD REPORT
THE OFFICE PLANNING AND THAT
WITH AN THE EFFECT OF I'M NOT.
AT PROVIDING REQUEST COVERAGE
AT LOWER COST CALIFORNIA FAIR
ACCESS TO INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS OF FAIR PLAY. AND
MODERN CHURCH PROGRESS ON THEIR
COMMITTEE. TO OFFER INSURANCE
POLICIES IN THOSE WILDFIRE FROM
COMMUNITIES SO IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT COMPANION PIECE TO
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU SIR OTHER FOLKS IN THE
VIDEO ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR. THE PRIME NUMBER FROM
THE SENATE INSURANCE COMMITTEE
HERE TO HELP ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. ARE THERE ANY
FOLKS ON THE TELEPHONE Q. UNDER
THE MODERATORS AWARE OF WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL. WE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF TODAY'S BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND NO ONE ISSUED UP THERE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHTS OTHER
PERSONS WHO WISH TO SPEAK
AGAINST THE BILL WAR IN OUR
VIDEO. LAUNCH ROOM MANY FOLKS
AGAINST THE BILL YES SIR. GO
AHEAD YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AND THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER CARLOTTA
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT INSURANCE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY TWO. PLEASE
KNOW THAT FOR SURE A LOT OF AND
THE DEPARTMENT TO NOT COME TO
THE DECISION TO OPPOSE ASK YOU
TO NINETY TWO LIGHTLY HOWEVER
SINCE AS BETWEEN NINETY TWO IS
DIRECTLY LINKED UP WITH
PENDING. AB TWENTY ONE SIX OR
SEVEN WHICH WE ALSO HAVE AN
OPPOSITION. LISTEN TO THAT BILL
THE DEPARTMENT IS VERY SIMILAR
CONCERNS. JENNIFER FOR BOTH.
BRIEFLY NOT SHELL S. SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY TO CREATE A
FAST TRACK AROUND CURRENT
ESTABLISHED PROPOSITION ONE OF
THREE RATED GROUP PROCESS AT
THE DEPARTMENT WITHOUT CLEAR
EVIDENCE THAT THE EXISTING RATE
SETTING PROCESS DOES NOT WORK.
AND WITHOUT ANY GUARANTEE OF
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR COVERAGE.
SECONDLY SENATE BILL TWO NINE
TO CIRCUMVENT THE AUTHORITY OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND
EXISTING DEPARTMENTS
REGULATIONS FOR REGULATING THE
USE OF COMPLEX. TO TACITLY
MODELS WHEN PROJECTED FUTURE
LOSSES. THIRDLY SENATE BILL TWO
NINE TWO PERMITS THE USE OF
EXPIRED RATES. THE INSURANCE
QUESTIONS EXISTING NETWORK
PROHIBITS EXCESSIVE AN ADEQUATE
OR UNFAIRLY DISCRIMINATORY
RATES AND DOES NOT ALLOW SUCH
RATES TO REMAIN IN EFFECT
HOWEVER THIS BILL WOULD
EXPRESSLY PROVIDING INSURER MAY
CONTINUE TO USE OLD ACTUALLY
UNSOUND INSURANCE MARKET ACTION
PLAN GRADES EVEN AFTER AND I'M
UP AS A NATION IT IS EXPIRED.
FOR BOTH INSURED AND RENEWED
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY INSURANCE
POLICY. ALL THIS BILL DIRECTS
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF REGIONALLY
SPECIFIC COMMITTEE HARDENING
STANDARDS AND HOME HARDEN
STANDARDS THROUGH A STATEWIDE
COMMISSION- WE- STATEWIDE
STANDARDS CAN BE ACTUALLY BE A
BENEFIT- WHICH THEY JUST. CAN'T
RELATE TO HIMSELF THIS BILL
EMBRACES THE NEW RATE MAKING
PROCESS THAT WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
AND SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
CONSUMERS INSURANCE PROGRAMS
OVER TIME. WHILE THE SAME TIME
WE CAN INCLUDES YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN THE RECORD
MAKING PROCESS. WITH THAT SAID-
WE DO BELIEVE THE CURRENT RATE
MAKING PROCESS PRESCRIBED UNDER
PROPOSITION ONE OF THREE IS
AVAILABLE FOR INSURERS REQUEST
ADEQUATE RATE TODAY FOR THESE
READINGS PLUS MRE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SIMPLE TO NINETY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MARTINEZ OTHER OTHER PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK AGAINST THE
BILL. ANYONE ELSE IN THE VIDEO
ROOM SPEAKING AGAINST THE BILL
IF NOT LET'S GO TO THE PHONES
TO THE MODERATOR DO HAVE
PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK
AGAINST THIS BILL. ANYONE
LOOKING TO SPEAK AGAINST THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND LOCAL TO LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY SIX ONE SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN DALY AND MEMBERS.
MIKE MADDUX COUNSEL FOR
CONSUMER WATCHDOG HERE IN
OPPOSITION AT THE TWO NINE TWO
AND HAPPY TO GET THROUGH THIS
TIME HAVING BEEN CUT OFF ON
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN. I KNOW
WHAT WHAT FIRST IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA VOTERS
PASSED PROPOSITION ONE AT THREE
REGULATE PROPERTY CATHOLIC
TEACHERS RIGHT. UNDER
PROPOSITION ONE OF THREE RATE
FOR HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE ARE
SUBJECT TO CONSISTENT AND
THOROUGH REGULATORY REVIEW AND
PUBLIC GROUP NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT INSURANCE IS FAIR
AVAILABLE AND AFFORDABLE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA. AT THE TWO NINE
TWO RECENTLY ABANDONED TO
OVERRIDE PROPERTIES WHEN I
BREEZED AFFECTION AGAIN ON.
ARBITRARY SECRET RATE. THIS
UNDERMINE THE OF VOTERS IN THE
ELECTED MEASURE TO DETERMINE
HOW WATER RATES ARE SET.
INCLUDING WHETHER TO USE MODEL
AT THAT RATE AND IF SO WHAT
MODEL THAT SERVES THE PUBLIC
NINETY THIRD. AT NINETY WOULD
ALLOW COMPANIES RETURNED TO THE
BRAIN BOB ONE OF DAY. IN WHAT
THAT BY INSURANCE IN WITH THE
LAW. SELECT A- AT THE NINETY
WILL RAISE HOME INSURANCE RIGHT
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA. I TIME WHEN
THE WAIT FOR I'M ALLOWING FOR
THE USE A BLACK BOX. WILDFIRE
WITH MY NOW WITH. FOR THE
PREMIUM POLICY RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY INTEREST BLOOD
PROBABLY. REVIEW PORTABILITY
CHALLENGE ANYTHING RELATED TO
THE BLACK BOX PROPRIETARY RISK
MODEL. DURING THE SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES INSURANCE COMPANIES
WERE FREE TO CHARGE WHATEVER
THEY WANTED FOR INSURANCE. AS A
RESULT CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE
MARKET PLACE WITH ROCK BY
MASSIVE WINGS IN THE BRIGHT THE
PHONE OTHER WOOD BUSINESS
THIRTY AND FIFTY STABILIZE ON.
A CREATED AND ARE YOU WERE THE
BUSINESS THAT. AND DESOLATE
RECOMMEND PRECLUDED EIGHT
BERMAN AREA BACK. THE CAR PARA.
THE RATE MAKING UP FORTY
INCLUDES USE OUT MODEL THE
FIFTY ONE WHICH NOTHING NOTHING
MORE THE FOR FIND COMPANIES OR
THEIR BANTER OF WHAT THEY THINK
NEEDS FOR LOTS OF MY- IN.
COMPANIES THAT FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO A BAD THAT YOUR
CLAIM. NOR TO ARGUE THAT MERITS
BUT THEY ARE PREMIUM. THIS IS
WHAT BETTER THE STATUS ARE YOU
AND THEN TRANSPARENT BY THE
REGULAR VENTURE RIGHT. AT THE
TWO NINE THE AMPLE BOB TO ABOUT
THE BURKE HOME SEPARATE STATE
REPORT ARTICLE BY THAT MEASURE
THE FORTY REGULATE MODEL. THE
CALL FOR THE CREATION OF BOTH
COMMISSION AND THEY HAVE
PROPERTY MARVELING AT. FROM THE-
HE'S SUPPOSED TO POLITICAL IS
IN VARIOUS STAKE HOLDERS
INSURANCE COMPANY THAT WILL A
PATH OF PUBLIC. ART IT BE
LOCKED UP. ON THE SECOND ONLINE
FOR YOU YOU START WITH THE DOC
IT. A HOUSEHOLD CREATURES
BRIDGE WITH THAT APPARENTLY A
FRIEND OF THE PROBLEM OF FREE
WILL DOUBLING HOMEOWNER
INSURANCE RIGHT. AN AT THE TWO
NINETY. ALLOWS INSURANCE
COMPANIES BIG BASS THE GROUP
HAVE RIGHT MAKE DECISIONS
MANDATED BY POP BREAK. ABOUT
TEXAS AND ONE ON POINT FOUR
STATE S. OF THE- TO PROTECT
PUBLIC WELL TO PROVIDE THIRD
PARTY HOW. WHAT IS DOCTOR
JARGON FOR THE REGULATION FOR
ALLOWING THE INSURANCE COMPANY
THAT BUT THEY'RE NOT FOR THE
INSURANCE THAT. THIS IS POP OUT
WHILE THE TEACHER FOR THE FIRE
THAT THE PROBLEM. IN SHORT AT
THE TWO NINETY WOULD ALLOW IT
TO SEVENTY FIVE ONE OF THE
PROTECT AGAINST UNSPECIFIED
RATE YOU SHOULD STOP THE PROPER
CLEARANCE JEFF OUTFIT FACTORED
WILL BE FUNDING EIGHT EUROPE
RADICAL PRIMITIVE. RIGHT FIFTY.
WITH OF THE CHURCH. FINALLY AT
THE DOES NOT LOOK WHICH IS
PROBABLY ONE THE BRICK.
OPPOSITION MORE BE SHOULD NOT
BE A FIVE ALLEGED SEX ACTS UP.
FOR THEIR PURPOSE OF THAT HAVE
ANY BUT THE THIRD BUT- THAT IS
MADE CLEAR BY THE- COURT AND
WHAT SPECIFICALLY A BURKE THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE. THAT A
MEMBER THE PROPER RATE FURTHER
PURPOSE THAT CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT AND AM WEST. AND AGAIN
BUT THE FOUNDATION FOR TAXPAYER
PROVIDES BURDENS. GARAMENDI IT.
AT TWO NINETY WITH THE NEXUS
PROPOSED AN UNLAWFUL USER OF
THE CAL BUT HAVE GIVEN YOUR
COMMISSIONER AND NOT WITH THE
BILL STATE INTENT DOES NOTHING
TO ADDRESS FINE CHANGE. DOES
NOT REQUIRE INSURANCE COMPANY A
NEW HOMEOWNER POLICY THE
PROTECTION THEN ANYWAY BOB. FOR
THE POST BALLPARK AVERAGE USE
THAT PLAGUE I'M THE GAL.
ACCORDING TO MY WATCH BACK YEAH
SO BOTH. THE TWO NINETY ONE AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. THANK YOU SIR OTHER
OTHER PERSONS IN LINE- IN THE
TELEPHONE Q. SPEAK TO GERRY
CURRENT SENSIBLE TO LINE UP.
YES HER NECK TO OPEN A LINE OF
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD. AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR I ACTUALLY AND-
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT I'M NOT
ABLE TO GET IN EARLIER ON
MEDICINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS KERA CROSSED
WITH A AYE OUR WORLDWIDE WE
HAVE A SUPPORT IF A MAN
POSITION ON THE BILL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND NONE IS THAT WE
BELIEVE WILL MAKE A PATH TO DO
MOBILE MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE
FOR USE BY INSURERS AND THE
PUBLIC MORE ACCURATELY
UNDERSTAND THE RISKS OF LOS. I
DIDN'T TO SAY THAT CURRENTLY
THE CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
AUTHORITY IS PERMITTED TO USE
CATASTROPHE MODEL IN THE STATE.
THE CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
AUTHORITY AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY MENTIONED WHAT APPROVED
BY THE LEGISLATURE. AND ALSO IN
FLORIDA AFTER HURRICANE-
CATCHER MODELS ARE WIDELY USED
AND RECOGNIZED AS AN
APPROPRIATE- USED TO ATTACK
BRETT- AND THEY ARE APPROVED-
BY SEPARATE COMMISSION AND THE
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
CROSS. IS MORE SELECT THE RIVER
MOTION SECOND OTHER OTHER.
FOLKS SPEAKING AGAINST THE BILL.
TO THE MODERATOR OTHER IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN LINE. GET THIRTY
TO HAVE ONE PERSON IN LINE-
WILL GO TO ONE NUMBER FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SENATOR
RUBIO AND MEMBERS ROBERT WHO
WELL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO ONE TWO.
FOR WELL ORAL ARE. MY PHONE
LINE IS WORKING JUST FINE. I'LL
I'LL BE MORE PROOF THAT MR
MATIC WAS. STILL UNFORTUNATELY
THE WORLD'S IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION THAT IS SAFE
CALIFORNIA BILLIONS OF HAPPY
DECADES. INDICATED THAT THE TWO
NINETY TWO FIRST OF THE
COMMISSION AND THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE CREATED BY THIS BILL
ARE DESIGNED IN SUCH A MANNER
SO AS TO IGNORE AND SHUT OUT
THE POLICE'S OF CONSUMERS.
DESPITE ASSERTIONS CHUCK MADE
BY THE CHURCH TO THE STREET A
FEW MOMENTS AGO THERE'S NO
BLOCK GROUP. OF STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED NO CONSUMER POLICY
HOLDER REPRESENTATIVE SERVE ON
EITHER OF THE COMMISSION OR THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. WHICH TO ME
IS VERY. SECOND AT TWO NINETY
TWO APPEARS TO. TISSUE FROM.
MODELS USED BY COMPANIES.
DURING THAT THE REGULATOR CAN
AND- THE BLACK BOX MODEL THEM
IF YOU WILL USE BY INSURERS AND
THE VENDORS WHO THEY HIRE TO
HELP THAT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR TRANSPARENT AND
FAIR WAY MAKING PROCESS. AT
BEST A GENEROUS INTERPRETATION
IS THAT THE BILL IS EXTREME
WORKING ON THIS POINT. THIS IS
RELEVANT TO SB TWO NINETY TWO
BECAUSE REGULATED INDUSTRIES
DESIRE WHAT IS KNOWN AS
REGULATORY CAPTURE. WHEREBY THE
REGULATED INDUSTRY ESSENTIALLY
PROHIBITS THE REGULATOR FROM
EFFECTIVELY DOING THEIR JOB AND
THE REGULATOR IS PERPETUALLY
FIVE STEPS BEHIND THE LATEST
INDUSTRY MODEL OR STANDARD. AND
CONSUMER SUFFERS IN THE
MEANTIME. CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION IN EFFECTIVE CONSUMER
FOCUSED INSURANCE INDUSTRY
REGULATION. NOW IS ABSOLUTELY
NOT THE MOMENT TO LET THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY DICTATE HOW.
THEY CAN BE REGULATEDTHE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY URGES
NO GO ON SB TWO NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU SIR. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER FOLKS IN THE
TELEPHONE Q. SIR THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. I WANT TO POINT OUT JUST A
COUPLE. OF ITEMS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY NOT HAVE
NOTICED IN THE CORRESPONDENCE
WE RECEIVED. IN A FEATURE OF
THE BILL WHICH I THINK IS VERY
HELPFUL THE FUTURE OF THE BILL.
REQUIRES THE STATE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH TO ISSUE
WHEN ACCOUNTABILITY REPORT THAT
ANALYZES THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS NEW PROGRAM. AT PROVIDING
MORE ROBUST COVERAGE AT LOWER
COST. THEN THE FAIR PLAN. AND
MONITORS THE INSURERS PROGRESS
ON THEIR COMMITMENT TO OFFER
HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE POLICIES
IN A WILDFIRE FROM COMMUNITY SO
THERE WILL BE AN ASSESSMENT
MADE- THE LEAST MEASURES TWO OF
THOSE. FEATURES THAT WAS A
QUESTION THAT MISTER WOOD HAD
ON MY BILL. SECONDLY I THINK
IT'S NOTEWORTHY THAT THE FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THEY LIKE THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF OVERSIGHT AND
ADVISORY GROUPS TO WORK THROUGH
THE COMPLICATED DETAILS OF WILD
FIRE RISK MITIGATION AND
INCENTIVES. THEY ALSO LIKE THE
PUBLIC MODELING. WITH THE
PUBLIC DATABASE OF HOUSING AND
WILD FIRE MITIGATION ACTIVITIES.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S NOT
WORTHY THAT TO FOX WHOSE FOCUS
IS FIRE PROTECTION THE FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THEY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR MS RUBIO ON HER
BILL MISTER BIGELOW. GOING ON
THAT SAME LINE MAYBE FOR FROM
THE AUTHOR WITH YOU GET A
LITTLE CLARIFICATION ON CAL
FIRE HAS BEEN DEVELOPING A
SERIES OF- OF ITS OWN WE
BUILDING CODES WHICH INCLUDES
COMPLEX MODELING AND LOOKING AT
HIGH HAZARD SAFETY AREAS- ZONES
AND PARCELS- WITHIN THOSE
ZONES. THE QUESTION REALLY IS
HOW WILL THIS BILL A LINE WITH
THEIR WORK. AND THE APPROPRIATE
PRODUCTS BEING USED BY THE
WILLIE AND ENSURE THAT THE
COMMISSION ISN'T. JUST
DUPLICATING- ANY OF THEIR
ACTIONS MAYBE YOU COULD HELP
ADDRESS THAT. WELL THANK YOU
AND I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO ALSO SPOKE ON THE PHONE I
HEARD THE CONCERNS AND I KNOW
THAT THAT. WE'RE FACING VERY
DIFFERENT TIMES AS WE KNOW THE
LAST FIVE YEARS HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATING. THE WORST FIRES
THAT WE'VE HAD AND SO TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION I ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WANTED TO STATE
FOR THE RECORD IS. DUE TO COVET
NINETEEN IT'S BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT TO CONNECT WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS BUT I CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS SO I WANT TO
ASSURE YOU THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN. UNTIL
WE MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT
TO PICK IT UP AND- THIS IS MORE
OF A LONG TERM TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT WE- TRY TO PROVIDE
CONSUMERS BETTER OPTIONS AND
THAT THEIR COVER ITSELF. RIGHT
NOW WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION AND I WILL ASSURE
YOU THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO MINIMIZE MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
DUPLICATING. AND SO THAT'S AS
BEST AS I CAN ANSWER IN TERMS
OF THE CONVERSATIONS WERE HAPPY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
RESPONSE I. DO AS A FORMER
COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND MANY OF
US HERE OF SERVED IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE'VE SEEN AND
WITNESSED OVER AND OVER. A
DUPLICATION OF ACTIONS THAT
OCCURRED AT. A COMPOUND IN
BILLS THE COSTS. FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO HELP THE
MOST SO. I APPRECIATE YOUR-
DIRECTNESS AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT. HOW HOW IT'S DIFFICULT
NOW TO. GET IN TOUCH WITH
EVERYONE AND TRY TO GET ALL
THESE ANSWERS AS BEST YOU CAN-
OFFERED ON A HEARING LIKE TODAY
BUT- PLEASE TAKE A GOOD DEAL OF
ATTENTION TO THAT SO WE DON'T
HAVE DUPLICATION OF ACTION. AND
COMPOUNDING OF COSTS FOR THEIR
PEOPLE I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
BILL I DO APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT IT'S GOING IN I THINK A
GOOD DIRECTION. AND LOOK FOR TO
SUPPORTING IT. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS MISTER WHAT IS A
QUESTION MISS CALM WATER HAS
QUESTION. AND MR BUT ACTUALLY
MISTER VOEPEL HAD IS MIKE UP
FIRST GO AHEAD SIR YES I
SUPPORT THIS BILL IT'S A GREAT
BILL WE NEEDED- AND HERE'S WHY.
MANY CARRIERS USE THE I- SO
RADIANT SYSTEM FOR FIRE HAZARD.
THE RATING SYSTEM GOES FROM ONE
TO TEN. PARADISE CALIFORNIA WAS
RAIDED A TWO SLASH TWO ACTS IT
IS STILL RATED AT TWO SLASH TWO
X. I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW I ALSO
CAME UP WITH THAT WHEN I WAS
MAYOR OF MY CITY. MY FIRE CHIEF
TOOK GREAT PRIDE IN GETTING THE
LOWEST ISO RATING POSSIBLE AND
PART OF THE FORMULA THERE IS
YOUR FIRE DEPARTMENT IT IS YOUR
FIRE HYDRANTS EXCEPT YEAH. I
LOOK AT THIS STUDY AS BEING
CRITICALLY NEEDED. BECAUSE NOT
JUST AYE SO BUT MANY CARRIERS
AND I WON'T NAME ON. DO NOT USE
I SO THEY HAVE THEIR OWN SYSTEM
FOR DOING FIRE RISK. AND THEY
CAN BASICALLY MAKE UP THEIR OWN
RULES. I ALSO SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE IT INCLUDES THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND
EMERGENCY SERVICES OFFICE. AS
JOINT CHAIR TO ME THAT'S A
GREAT STRUCTURE SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS AND I HOPE TO
SEE IT WORK AND I BELIEVE IT
WILL HELP. CORRECT SOME OF THE-
DANGEROUS PRACTICES. IN THE
HIGH FIRE WRIST AREAS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. MISS PROM
LONGER. THANK YOU MISTER I JUST
HAD A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
WAS WONDERING IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE LETTERS
OF OPPOSITION THAT THIS WOULD
IN FACT INCREASE RATES. THAT'S
MY QUESTION WHAT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I THINK I HEARD ON
T. V. SO ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
WAS TALKING ABOUT PROP ONE ALL
THREE AND I THINK IT WAS THE
SHARED RIGHT NOW- AGAIN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I WANT TO
EXPRESS THAT THE PEOPLE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT HE GOT UP FROM
CONSUMERS. AT EVERY LEVEL OF
CONVERSATION THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER WILL BE ABLE TO
FULLY REVIEW THE MODEL AND THAT
MAKE SURE THAT HE BACKS IT IS
PART OF THE CONVERSATION AND
PROTECTS CONSUMERS WITH NOT
SOMETHING WE'RE JUST GONNA
CREATING GOAL FOR WEIGHT IT'S
GONNA HAVE PROFESSIONAL INPUT-
STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND CONSUMER
INPUT WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THAT IS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION SO. AREN'T IS TO
MAKE IT BETTER FOR CONSUMERS
NOT MAKE IT WORK SO WE WILL
WORK TO ENSURE THAT THAT. MR
WOULD EUROPE. THANK YOU- I JUST
WANNA SAY I INTEND TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODA BUT I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- I WAS
SURPRISED THIS WE RESET YOUR
STAFF AND I ASKED THEM- FOR THE
LISTING COUNTIES THAT WOULD BE
AFFECTED BY THIS I WAS
SURPRISED AND DISAPPOINTED
QUITE FRANKLY THIS COUNTY WHERE
I LIVE- IS NOT ON THE LIST- BUT
SEE WE HAD- I DON'T KNOW
THIRTEEN AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS IN LOSSES IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN- TO THAT THE
NINETEEN WE HAVE THE LARGEST.
FIRE BY ACREAGE. IN THE THREE
OF THE COUNTY. AND YET SOMEHOW.
IT DOESN'T QUALIFY HERE. FOR
THIS SO- I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT QUITE FRANKLY COUPLE THE
OTHER COUNT AS A REPRESENT DO
BUT- BUT- I'M YOU KNOW I'M I
WANT TO LOOK AT THIS FURTHER
AND SEE- YOU KNOW WHAT WAY WHY
THIS I AND WHAT THE
EXPLANATION AS- I AM CONCERNED
THERE ARE A MILLION HOMES NOW
THAT HAVE- HAD REYES FROZEN. BY
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LARA AND
I'M I AM WONDERING- QUITE
FRANKLY WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WHEN THAT FREEZE COMES OFF AND
I MY INSTINCT IS THAT THOSE
RATES ARE GOING TO GO OUT AND
THAT THAT CONCERNS ME THAT
CONCERNS ME AS WELL SOME OF THE
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY- BUT I'M
IN A RESERVE THE RIGHT TO- NOT
SUPPORTED ON THE FLOOR IF I
DON'T MY QUESTIONS ANSWERED.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY WITH
RESPECT TO THE CHAIRS BILL I
SUPPOSE SUPPORT THAT BILL AND I
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO-
RECONSIDER THAT ON THE FLOOR I
AM STILL CONCERNED THAT THIS
COULD LEAD TO A SPIKE IN AND
RATES- THAT THAT WOULD MAKE IT-
YOU KNOW I FIND ACCEPTABLE FOR
A LOT OF PEOPLE. SO DO YOU HAVE
ANY INSTINCT ORDERS MY
INSTINCT- THE ONLY ONE DO YOU
HAVE ANY ANSWERING TO WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN THAT THAT
RATE FREEZE AB COME HAPPENS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION OF
COURSE YOU KNOW YOUR AREA
DESERVES AS MUCH CARE AS IT SB
ENTIRE CALIFORNIA BUT IT'S A
SPECIFIC REASON WHY THAT
HAPPENED AND I HAVE ONE OF MY
STAFF MEMBERS THAT WE CAN
DEFERRED TO HAND YOU CAN
EXPLAIN WHY YOU'RE COUNTY WITH
LEFT OUT AND I HAVE TO DO WITH
THE PREVIOUS BILL AND STILL
TRYING TO PIECE ON. A LATE. MR
SOME MEMBER IN RESPONSE TO YOUR-
IT IS QUITE SURPRISING-
INITIALLY THAT. THE COUNTY OF
SADDAM WOULD BE OFF THE LIST
BUT IT IS I BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS FOR KIND O ONE MAIN REASON.
THAT IS THAT SB EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR PROVIDES PROTECTION. FOR
ZIP CODES THAT WERE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY SO. FOR THE LAST-
SOCIALLY FOR YEARS I'VE BEEN TO
DEVASTATING FIRES THAT HAVE
ALLOWED- THE PEOPLE IN CINEMA
TO KEEP THEIR INSURANCE WHEREAS
OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE. OF
THE DO NOT HAVE THIS PROTECTION
HAVE BEEN NON RENEWED. AND I'VE
GONE INTO THE FAIR PLAN. SO I
BELIEVE THAT IN THE FUTURE THAT
IF THOSE PROTECTIONS EXPIRE.
THAT INSURERS WILL AGAIN.
COMMIT TO DO MORE LAW WE WILL
IN YOUR AREA AND OTHER AREAS.
AND ASK THOSE HOMEOWNERS- RELY
ON FAIR PLAN FOR THEIR
INSURANCE- THE SYSTEM SET UP
WILL CAPTURE THAT INFORMATION.
AND QUALIFY THE COUNTY- WHEN IT
REACHES EXCUSE ME THE THRESHOLD.
THANK YOU. SO IF I UNDERSTAND
IT IT THERE'S A POSSIBILITY
ONCE WAS PROTECTIONS GO WAY
THAT MY COUNTY WILL NOW BE
ELIGIBLE UNDER THIS IS AT THAT
FAIR. THE CURRENT PROTECTIONS
BASED ON ZIP CODES THAT WHICH
IS THAT SUCH A WHAT YOU'VE SAID.
OKAY YEAH THE CURRENT
PROTECTIONS BASED ON ZIP CODE.
ROLL ALLOW LOOKS IN ON THE
COUNTY TO NOT DEAL WITH AS MANY
ON RULES BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT THE INSURERS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO NON RENEW THEIR
HOMEOWNER'S BUT IT'S PRETTY
WELL CORRELATED THAT WOULD NOT
RULES EXCEED A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF THEIR PLAN WILL HAVE A
SEARCH- IN THAT AREA BECAUSE
THE OTHER INSURERS ARE AT THEIR
CONCENTRATION OF THAT AND NOT
ABLE TO WRITE A MORE POLICY
THIS TYPE OF MARKET CONTRACTION
LOCALLY IS WHAT THE SYSTEM IS
DESIGNED TO MONITOR AND-
EVALUATE IN REAL TIME- ON AN ON
AN ONGOING BASIS IN ORDER TO-
PROVIDE- YOU KNOW OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS THERE WILL BE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT COUNTIES THAT WOULD
NOT BE ELIGIBLE NOW. THAT WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR AND I AM NOT
PROGRAM YOU ASSUMING THAT THERE
ARE MORE DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
AND MORE NOT RULES. OKAY THAT
WAS THE FIRST WAS WITH THE
SECOND QUESTION WAS THE MILLION
HOMES THAT HAVE HAD THEIR RATES
FROZEN. WHAT WE EXPECT WHEN
THAT WENT UP WHEN THAT FREEZE
ENDS WHICH I BELIEVE WILL
HAPPEN LATER THIS YEAR. IF I'M
NOT CORRECT I'M NOT SURE WHEN
IT'S GOING TO END. BUT I GUESS
THAT'S UP TO THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER- WHEN THAT HAPPENS
BUT- I CAN'T HELP BUT THINK
THAT THE RATES ARE GOING TO GO
OUT. WHEN THAT HAPPENS SO. AND
IT'S A VALID CONCERN AND AS I
MENTIONED AGAIN THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER A IS GOING TO BE
PART OF THIS PROCESS EVERY STEP
OF THE WAY. SO THERE IS
PROTECTION IN THAT RESPECT AND
AS BRIAN MENTIONED OP. I TO
YOUR OHER QUESTION RIGHT NW
BECAUSE YOU DO HAVE THAT
PROTECTION- WITH WHAT ANY BE.
IT WASN'T INCLUDED BUT ONCE
IT'S UP. THIRTY BASED ON THE
NON RENEWAL AND A FAIR CAN
SEARCH. IT WILL TRIGGER. THE
AYE MAP PROTECTION FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY. WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO
QUESTION THE ELIGIBILITY OF A
COUNTY. AND IT APPEARS THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN PROVISIONS IN
LINE NOW OF THE TO. THAT ARE IN
EFFECT BUT IN THE SEQUENCE OF
EVENTS THAT. AT THE CINEMA
COUNTY FOR INSTANCE MAY BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE BUT I FOR ONE
WILL BE WATCHING THAT I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT- MATTER.
AND WE WANT THIS TO WORK
WHEREVER IT'S NEEDED I THINK
THAT'S THE GOAL LET'S KEEP OUR
EYE ON THE BALL THERE AND. I
RESPECT THE SENATE STAFFER IN
HIS- HIS REASONING ON THE OTHER
HAND WE DO WANT THIS TO WORK
FOR HOMEOWNERS IN FIRE RISK
AREAS AT SOME POINT SO THE
ELIGIBILITY BY ANY COUNTY IS A
IS AN IMPORTANT. IMPORTANT
POINT. A BIG HANK YOU TO OPT
ANY COMMENT AGAIN- I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT- WHAT I'M HEARING
THOUGH IS THAT. THE CITIZENS OF
THE COUNTY HAVE ALREADY
SUFFERED CATASTROPHIC LOSSES
ONCE THE PROTECTION OF THE ZIP
CODE PROTECTION HAPPENS THEY'RE
GONNA GET TO SUFFER AGAIN.
BEFORE THEY GET TO QUALIFY
POTENTIALLY FOR THIS PROGRAM
AND THAT'S WHAT CONCERNS ME.
YEAH AND- I THINK WE I THINK WE
NEED TO KEEP AN EYE ON THIS AND
I'LL BE OPPORTUNITIES TO FINE
TUNE IT. AND CERTAINLY THE
THRUST O THE BILL IS SOMETHING
THAT I CONTINUE TO SUPPORT AND-
I'M READ RECOMMENDING IN FAVOR
OF IT BUT THAT'S THAT'S A
QUESTION NEEDS TO BE DEALT
WITH. YEAH I WANTED A SHERMAN
AT HIM AS WELL SORRY FAMILY
MEMBER THAT I HEAR YOUR
CONCERNS AND AGAIN THE
LIMITATION OF OUR BEING IN THE
BUILDING AND HAVING HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS- BUT SOME
LIMITATIONS BUT I WILL SIT DOWN
WITH YOU TO ENSURE THAT WE
TACKLE YOUR PARTICULAR SHIRT.
AND THAT THEY'RE NOT LEFT OUT
OF THE PROCESS. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO I THINK WE'VE-
WE'VE HEARD ALL THE COMMENTS
THAT TO. THAT WERE MEANT TO BE
MADE. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
IF NOT TO MISS RUBIO YOU'RE
WELCOME TO CLOSE YOUR REMARKS
WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK FOR
BEFORE YOU- I CAN IT'S A WORK
IN PROGRESS- FULLY COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT ALL THE-
CONCERNS NOT ONLY ADDRESSED
HERE ON THE FLOOR BUT ON THE
PHONE AS WELL. THAT WE TRY TO
ENSURE THAT ALL VOICES ARE
HEARD CONCERNS ARE ALSO- TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION AND THEN
COME TO A SOLUTION THAT THAT
EIGHT SATISFIED EVERYONE IT'S
AN APPLICATION THANK YOU. GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS. HAS A
RECOMMENDATION TO SUPPORT. IF
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
SO WE'LL DO A ROLL CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS DALY AYE DALY
AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE BERMAN
BERMAN AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW I
RIVAS. RIVAS I CHEN CHEN AYE
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER
I FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE GIPSON
GIPSON GRAYSON. GRAYSON HI
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I WILL TELL
VOEPEL I WOULD. WHAT. WOULD I
THINK JUST FOURTEEN ZERO. THAT
BILL PASSES UNANIMOUSLY THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
SENATOR WILL BE IN TOUCH WITH
YOU ON AS WE GO FORWARD THANK
YOU AGAIN. WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR- GREAT
PARTICIPATION AND THANK MISTER
MAYES FOR A HIS VICE CHAIR
ASSISTANCE AND I THINK
EVERYONE'S VOTED DISORDERS NO
ADD ONS NOTHING OUT ON. I DON'T
WANT TO CLOSE THE HEARING A-
PREMATURELY WE CLOSE IT WE'RE
DONE. THE HEARING IS CLOSED.
WE'RE